[Musique]
yves jégo bonsoir bonsoir toujours selon
pour une chaîne un terrain qui s'appelle
thinker view nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement je m'appelle yves jégo je
suis né en 1961
j'ai fait plusieurs choses dans ma ville
d'apolitique pas mal
j'ai été avocat j'ai été consultant dans
une société de ressources humaines et
aujourd'hui je me bats pour le made in
france et pour les entreprises
françaises alors yves gigou vous avez
fait de la politique vous avez mangé à
conviendra tout les deux partis
politiques à plein je vais commencer au
rpr non j'ai même commencé à fréquenter
lorsque j'étais jeune les jeunes
giscardiens dans ma ville natale de
besançon puis assez vite moi qui étais
fils de modestes commerçants jeu c'était
les uns et les enfants des notaires des
médecins qui me montrait bien que je ne
faisais pas partie de leur monde et donc
j'ai adhéré pour la première fois un
parti politique à cause grâce à jacques
chirac qui était le rpr pas très
longtemps après sa fondation
j'ai suivi ensuite laventure politique
du rpr qui s'est fusionnée dans l'ump
d'ailleurs soul sous l'autorité de
chirac président de la république c'est
au moment où il a été confronté à jean
marie le pen et puis ensuite
j'ai suis devenu ministre de nicolas
sarkozy
toujours sur l'étiquette ump j'ai été un
temps porte parole de l'ump donc j'étais
mouillé à fond dans le parti politique
et lorsque je me suis fait virer du
gouvernement parce que on considérait
que j'avais géré de façon trop agressive
pour le patronat local la crise
en guadeloupe et aux antilles
j'ai participé avec jean louis borloo à
la création de lui des i avec cette idée
de retrouver au fond ce qui était ma
nature c'est à dire plus au centre de la
vie politique plus ce qu'on pouvait
appeler un temps je ne sais pas si c'est
encore la valeur mais le gaullisme
social c'est-à-dire la conciliation
entre le libéralisme que
mon approche politique et puis et puis
une forme de déquilibre dans la vie
politique
ce qu'on appelle le centre avec toutes
les complexités que sont le centre
plutôt les centres parce qu'il ya plein
de centrisme entre face au bo et les
autres c'est très compliqué voilà donc
politiquement je vais manger à 3 râle
teulier s'ils voulaient savoir combien
de cartes différentes parties politiques
qui était le rpr l'ump puis lui dit à
travers le parti radical puisque lui dit
c'était compliqué c'est un rassemblement
de partis politiques à tout ça est très
complexe et tout ça est complètement
incompréhensible pour les citoyens
beaucoup avaient arrêté la politique
parce que je faisais des choses
passionnantes j'étais vice-président de
l'assemblée nationale j'avais été réélu
brillamment
député je faisais des choses
passionnantes
j'avais des conditions de confort de vie
sociale intéressante mais que j'avais le
sentiment de ne pas assez pesé sur les
choses et et je menais par exemple un
combat qui met toujours cher celui des
menus végétariens dans les cantines
publiques voyez pour essayer d'habituer
les enfants à manger un peu différemment
pour qu'on consomme un peu moins de
viande dans l'avenir parce qu'on sait
que la consommation de viande porte
beaucoup sur l'émission de gaz à effet
de serre et que c'est assez nuisibles à
la planète et qu'il faut commencer
habitués les générations qui viennent à
manger moins de viande et que les menus
végétariens répondre à cette
problématique et j'ai vu au moment du
vote de la loi et galim sur
l'alimentaire combien les lobbys et et
transversaux combien
le sco pourrait appeler le lobby de la
viande est un enfant aux fêtes puissant
et je me suis dit après tout ça
c'est pas là qu'on fera bouger les
choses il faut aller peut-être dans la
société civile faut essayer de faire
bouger les choses de l'extérieur donc
j'ai quitté la vie politique j'ai décidé
de partir de moi même j'étais c'était en
2018 sur ce sujet j'ai d'ailleurs posé
ma dernière question écrite ma dernière
question orale j'ai été applaudi par
tout l'hémicycle de jean-luc mélenchon à
marine le pen au premier ministre
edouard philippe tout le monde était
debout pour me saluer comme tous ceux
qui s'en vont ils sont toujours très
grand quand ils s'en vont et surtout
j'ai été interpellé par des gens qui
dans les couloirs musée à quai c'était
courageux et au bout d'un an je suis une
merde j'ai peut-être fait un truc que
devait pas mesuré les choses si tout le
monde me dit que je suis courageux en
quoi suis-je courageux la question la
question de pourquoi j'étais courageux
pour quitter non mais c'est quoi vous
donner ma dernière question elle était
sûre elle portait sur au fond
l'antiparlementarisme sûr
une forme de populisme qui vise à faire
porter sur les parlementaires sur les
élus tous les maux du monde alors je
veux bien reconnaître que la classe
politique a beaucoup de responsabilités
puisque ça elle qu'on donne les clés et
qu'elle n'en mène pas forcément les pays
dans le bon sens mais au fond je disais
lors de cette question peut-être nous
nous sommes que le reflet d'un problème
de société plus qui va au delà de nous
et peut-être que si les politiques sont
médiocres peut-être que la société
devrait s'interroger aussi sur ce miroir
grossissant qu'est la politique c'était
manière sûre ça c'est très intéressant
le fait qu' on a les politiques qu'on
mérite mais on va commencer l'autrement
avant votre arrivée j'ai proposé à la
communauté de s'exprimer avec un gif
pour nous donner le curseur de
l'intensité que j'allais vous m et alors
c'est aussi lié entre le lance-flammes
dévoré par les loups a plus ou sabre
laser et j'en passe et les millions
alors ma question c'est pourquoi vous
comment vous expliquer la défiance des
français à cette caste politique d'abord
je pense pas que ce soit que les
français je pense qu'il ya une défiance
mondiale vis-à-vis de ceux qui nous
représentent que le populisme qu'on a vu
triompher aux états-unis en
grande-bretagne dans un certain nombre
de pays est la traduction d'une forme de
défiance parce qu'au fond les populistes
ils se font élire en disant c'est tous
des pourris et tous des [__] voté
pour nous vous verrez on est bien
meilleure et puis toujours beaucoup de
déception derrière tout ça
je
je pense que l'analyse et les multiples
naturellement il ya beaucoup de gens
très savants qui ont fait cette analyse
moi je pense que nous sommes le miroir
grossissant des problèmes de la société
et dans un monde qui change à toute
vitesse c'est la caractéristique de
notre époque par rapport à l'époque de
mes parents de nos parents nos grands
parents nos arrière-grands-parents les
changements sont extrêmement brutaux
changements démographiques qu'on a une
planète qui grossit à toute vitesse on
était un peu moins de 2 milliards en
on va être potentiellement cent
cinquante ans après 10 milliards c'est
du jamais vu dans l'histoire de
l'humanité où aucune génération n'a
connu un tel choc démographique le choc
et ça entraîne le choc écologique parce
qu'au fond on est nombreux on consomme
mal on pollue on va détruire
l'environnement premier choc qui nous
contraint deuxième show que la
transformation techniques technologiques
digital alors vous en êtes un modèle
veut transformer les médias mais il ya
plein de côté positif puis aussi des
côtés ou la disruption inquiète ou quand
on nous explique qu'on ne connaît pas
les métiers qu'ils exerceront nos
enfants parce que plus de la moitié des
métiers des 30 prochaines années sont
méconnus aujourd'hui ça crée de
l'inquiétude et ces changements créé de
l'angoissé est au fond le politique il
est le coupable d'être incapable
d'expliquer de rassurer et dans un
panier pays comme la france qui est un
pays particulièrement complexe de toute
façon dans un système démocratique de
démocratie d'opinion où l'opinion pèse
et organise la journée moi j'étais
milices ma journée et encore c'était il
ya dix ans ma journée était organisée
par la une du journal du matin qu'ils
disent est ce que j'allais faire dans la
journée il n'y a pas assez de recul il
n'y a pas assez de temps pour changer
les choses en profondeur et en douceur
le politique surf sur la vague le
politique n'a pas la chance comme moi ce
soir d'avoir beaucoup de temps pour
s'exprimer on verra si c'est intéressant
vous aurez du temps ou sinon si vous me
verrez mais je raconte souvent cette
anecdote à l'époque où je dirigeais la
campagne des élections européennes
de l'ue dei et du modem j'avais été
invité au journal de claire chazal sont
des intentions non mais je vous dis
juste ça parce que j'avais été invité au
journal de claire chazal sur tf1 et il
me dit ça va on a du temps pour parler
de l'europe c'est important on a du
temps je dis clair on a combien de temps
trois minutes cinquante bêtes tout est
dit comment voulez-vous en trois minutes
50 parler d'une problématique aussi
importante et donc l'homme politique je
pense qu'il est le réceptacle de tout ça
et que comme ils demandent du pouvoir
comme il dit votez pour moi j'aurai le
pouvoir et comme il fait des promesses
en disant je vais vous améliorer la vie
ça ne marche jamais il est donc coupable
de tout c'est pas une façon se dit
d'oignies c'est pas une façon se
déculpabiliser du meraz misérabilisme de
l'impuissance de la caste politique
c'est pas une façon d'erreur alors je
suis d'accord on a les politiques qu'on
mérite mais des deux boules
c'était quoi c'était un épiphénomène
c'était quoi tes de gaulle des napoléons
d il ya des moments où dans l'histoire
des chocs font font naître un personnage
qui surpasse les autres par sa
personnalité par sa capacité à faire je
pense qu'il peut apparaître demain un de
gaulle qui peut apparaître demain mais
mais mais mais mais ces personnages-là
n'apparaissent en général que sur des
chocs que sur des chocs violents et
profond et est dans le train train dans
la routine de nos sociétés qui vont bien
en tout cas
qu'ils vont bien qu'ils n'ont pas de
grands chocs pas de grande guerre
jusqu'à la pandémie sur ce sujet je
pense que c'est la difficulté à faire
apparaître des grands hommes politiques
et que le système est un système qui
parce qu'il écrase le message passe qui
vous permet pas vraiment de vous
exprimer longuement parce que en france
nous sommes un pays d'une complexité
absolue regardez ce qui se passe sur les
vaccins et on a compris la complexité
parce que c'est moi je vais vous la
résumer très simplement on a commandé
des vaccins au mois de novembre
faut pas s'étonner qu'on ait pris du
retard on a peint hip hip ou qui
commande les vaccins innovants n'avait
pas de masque donc on a pris du retard
mais mais ça si ce n'était que ça et que
derrière une logistique parfaite
organisé huilé on aurait pu le rattraper
le retard mais il ya une telle
complexité entre ceux qui décident au
sommet et la façon dont on agit sur le
territoire que ça accroît encore ce
phénomène quand on essaie complexité
c'est qu'aussi des strates de
l'administration exactement défend son
petit bout de gras pour légitimer son
salaire c'est pour légitimer un peu de
pouvoir à gauche à droite c'est quoi je
vais essayer de vous donner comme il
fait très froid une image
si vous mettez vos efforts vous mettez
un pull puis un deuxième puis un
troisième puis un quatrième il arrive à
un moment au 20e pull vous pouvais plus
bouger et bien notre pays depuis je
pense de siècle depuis sans doute
colbert depuis que le jeune louis xiv a
dit l'état c'est moi depuis qu'on a
incarné l'état comme étant tout puissant
a créé plein de structures pour plein de
bonnes raisons chaque poule pris
individuellement et une bonne
justification mais l'accumulation de
tout ça fait qu'on peut plus bouger dans
un monde où il faudrait bouger vite dans
un monde où l'adaptation et était d'un
impératif où l'agilité d'un impératif
parce que le monde va plus vite parce
qu'on a une accélération de l'histoire
et notre système politique est un
système qui ne permet pas d'aller vite
alors moi je n'accuse pas plus la
technostructure que les politiques que
les français aussi un qui sont aussi
demandeurs j'ai été pendant 16 ans
parlementaire je voyais des chefs
d'entreprise qui me disait monsieur jégo
c'est trop compliqué hein faut
simplifier on n'en peut plus puis le
même chef d'entreprise quinze jours
après il venait me voir avec son
syndicat professionnel en dix ans et on
a un problème il nous faudrait une petit
pois pour bien nous protéger là si vous
pouviez faire un texte un peu compliqué
qui nous protège on serait bien content
c'est le paradoxe français c'est
clientélisme st non ce nom c'est les
paradoxes de ce pays on veut des choses
contraires contradictoires on veut moins
de morts sur les routes mais on a du mal
à freiner il faut mettre de permis à
points pour y arriver nous sommes dans
une époque de paradoxes dans un peuple
paradoxal et gérer ses paradoxes c'est
extraordinairement compliquée bien sûr
que les politiques ont leur part de
responsabilité ils ont bien sûr qu'ils
encourent ils ont fait quoi c'est quoi
c'est la corruption alors qu'est-ce qui
explique plus cette défiance c'est quoi
c'est cette corruption cette déconnexion
le fait d'être au dessus des lois le
fait de pouvoir regarder manger du petit
homard je sais pas des gueuletons qu'on
vous étiez parlementaire ouais enfin pas
plus que qu'autrement hockeyeurs pas
plus que les politiques pas plus que
n'importe qui d'autre bon jeu très bien
ou très mal enfin jeu et puis lire les
choses aujourd'hui les choses d'hier
avec les yeux d'aujourd'hui ok on veut
des politiques qu'ils soient exemplaires
c'est tout à fait légitime et c'est tout
à fait respectable mais on veut aussi
qu'ils incarnent l'état la puissance une
forme de de majesté si j'ose dire parce
que c'est comme ça c'est culturel donc
c'est contradictoire on est aussi sur
cette contradiction là je pense que
c'est plus grave que ça c'est plus grave
que la corruption c'est plus grave que
celui qui va profiter du système
c'est que nous sommes au fond face à des
politiques qui qui n'ose pas dire qu'ils
n'ont plus de pouvoir
et que les grands phénomènes qui
contraignent l'époque elle dépasse le
politique elle dépasse le national vous
croyez que la pandémie est le politique
qui court derrière et encore seulement
ils courent mal vous croyez que les
phénomènes que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
de démographie que les phénomènes de 2,2
de disruption technologie que le
politique qui peut y faire quelque chose
vous croyez que l'économie se souvenait
de françois hollande disant mon ennemi
c'est la finance il y a t-il pu faire
rentrer la finance et donc le politique
vend un pouvoir qu'il n'a plus d'accord
donc d'où la déception comment ça se
passe dans un parti politique il ya le
financement des campagnes comment ça se
passe
aujourd'hui moi j'ai connu l'époque où
le financement des campagnes c'était
démerde toi pour aller trouver des
entreprises qui est qui te payes tes
affiche il ya très longtemps il ya 40
ans qui te grèce un peu gros ou kid
grèce un peu et aujourd'hui c'est
réguler c'est encadré par des règles par
des limites et c'est donc voilà
aujourd'hui quand on fait de la
politique on est beaucoup moins en
insécurité de ce point de vue là en
respectant les règles que ne pouvait
l'être ceux qui à 40 ou 50 ans essayez
de trouver des moyens de financer leur
campagne électorale il ya eu des progrès
de fait sur ce sujet un security si si
quand ça d insécurité ça commence par
les banques c'est à dire qu'ils
financent ou départ c'est des banques
qui détiennent à ce que vous appelez
comme campagne électorale si c'est une
campagne présidentielle ou si c'est des
campagnes plus local sis et des
campagnes locales c'est des financements
love money comment dire de gens qui sont
si c'est une campagne présidentielle
c'est beaucoup d'argent sur des
campagnes présidentielles on a vu
d'ailleurs dans un passé pas si lointain
les difficultés qu'avaient certains
partis je pense au front national a
trouvé à trouver des financements je
pense aussi à des parties plus
extrémistes à trouver des financeurs et
des financements sur ce sujet et on n'a
jamais regardé souvenez vous il y avait
un projet de l'actuel gouvernement qui
était d'ailleurs porté par françois
bayroux pendant le court temps où il
était garde des sceaux qui était un
projet de créer une sorte de banque
publique pour justement financer de
façon très transparente des campagnes
électorales ça n'a jamais vu le jour
donc là il ya encore un grand non dit
dans la vie politique qui est le
financement des campagnes électorales
présidentielles même si elles sont sous
le contrôle du conseil constitutionnel
il ya sans doute beaucoup de progrès à
faire en train de constitutionnel le
conseil constitutionnel il n'a pas dit
que la campagne de c'était balladur qui
était pour un âge mais ils ont quand
même validé c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'ai lu aussi ouais c'est normal ça
c'est pas normal si c'est vrai c'est pas
normal lequel lequel edouard balladur
est quand même devant les tribunaux à 93
ans sur des financement de sa campagne
électorale on peut pas dire non plus que
le système laisse tout passer à tout le
monde on n'est pas une république
bananière non mais on est ont voté de
tiers-mondisation je sais pas j'espère
que non pourquoi
pourquoi j'espère qu'on n'est pas en
voter parce que je pense que le le le la
hauteur de ce qui est arrêté les 5 ou 1
c'est du délit non c'est non j'espère
que nous
les infos que vous étiez dans un hôpital
c'était ou quand la dernière fois que
j'étais dans l'hôpital c'était dans
l'hôpital de montereau dont j'ai assuré
pendant 22 ans la présidence du conseil
de surveillance et que je
visite régulièrement parce que je suis
encore membre du conseil de surveillance
et et j mesure
la pauvreté les difficultés le manque de
moyens qui est un des fléaux de notre
pays alors que quand on regarde les
chiffres macro économie la dépense
sociale les prélèvements sociaux sont à
des plus élevés d'europe on a un
problème quelque part c'est à dire qu'on
prélève le plus d'europe
pour le social et les grands systèmes me
semble moins bien marché qu'ailleurs il
falloir qu'on se pose d'un problème des
clio tri ou est-ce que ça fuit ou est-ce
que ça merde ou est-ce que ça bug sur ce
sujet là il ya des vraies questions
quant macron disait sans doute un peu
malade maladroitement on prélève un
pognon dingue c'était pas pour dire que
ton pognon oui mais c'était pas pour
dire que c'était mal c'était pour dire
on met beaucoup il ya beaucoup d'eau au
dessus et il y arrive rien sur le en bas
ou c ou sa fuite par tous donc il faut
se poser ces questions est ce qu'on a
besoin d'autant d'administration du
social est ce que moi j'ai écrit un
livre il ya quelques années où je
faisais quelques propositions un peu
révolutionnaire sur les questions
sociales et les questions fiscales les
deux choses un peu révolutionnaire moi
je devrais réussir mon niveau le titre
du livre c'est marine le pen arriverait
au pouvoir sauf si et le thème du leem
c'était d'essayer d'expliquer ce que vus
de ma fenêtre j'imaginais qu'il faudrait
faire pour empêcher les populistes
d'arriver au pouvoir sur ce sujet eh
bien je soulignais deux choses c'est
l'hyper complexité de notre fiscalité
moi j'ai voté comme parlementaire
pendant 16 ans la fiscalité je suis
incapable de vous expliquer la fiscalité
française il faut éviter parce que j'ai
voté parce qu'il fallait bien voter des
budgets pour l'état et parce que parti
qui vous le demander bah c'était le
système qui me demandait oui et parce
que pour comprendre toute la fiscalité
il faut être très ils tracent
spécialisés etc les parlementaires ne
sont pas ultra spécialisée dans les
domaines de dire que les parlementaires
sont des benêts qui votent ce concours
donne mon nom je suis en train de vous
dire que dans un pays complexe
l'administration a le pouvoir parce que
elle elle gère la paix
la complexité que celui qui dirige
qu'elle a pour deux ans trois ans cinq
ans il devient pas un spécialiste à
fiscalité sinon tous les députés
seraient des avocats fiscalistes qui
serait payé des grosses honoraires
ces plaignants députés ont par exemple
un parlementaire aujourd'hui
c'était en est je parle en est
cinq mille cinq ou six mille euros par
mois et des frais dits demande à qui
aujourd'hui sont font l'objet d'un
contrôle extrêmement précis où ils sont
à peu près de la même somme ils ont été
réussis défraiement dernier je sais pas
je quittais parlement depuis trois ans
donc je ne sais pas sur ceux sur ce
sujet mais
pour rester sur ces sur les sujets de la
complexité
notre système social on parlait du
social et des hôpitaux personne ne sait
même l'aja tiers mondisation même la
chambre régionale des comptes même la
cour des comptes ne sais pas combien la
dette sociale en france
et les guichets de distribution des
différentes aides sociales sont
multiples sont nombreux c'est là où sont
les fuites du tuyau on est plus efficace
la dépense sociale on prélève beaucoup
et moi ça me dérange pas qu'on prélève
beaucoup c'est sans doute mon côté
centriste mais je voudrais que si on
prélève beaucoup on est des hôpitaux qui
soit bien meilleure qu'ailleurs qu'on
ait les moyens qu'il faut là où il faut
et qu'on n'est pas une administration
qui gère tout ça qui soit tellement
compliqué quelques jeux le coût de
gestion de la dépense sociale emporte
une partie de ce qui devrait arriver sur
le terrain c'est ça la problématique on
fait revenir sur le la tiers-mondisation
un peu plus tard miron on va on va
repartir sur la
le côté pesant tse d'administration vous
décrivez d'une façon
lente ineffective improductive est ce
que les politiques se retrouvent quand
ils sont élus coincé par en fait les
réelles tenant de du pouvoir français
c'est-à-dire l'administration est ce
qu'un politique peut pas se sacrifier
faire le grand ménage dans cette
administration où ils préfèrent
continuer le ronron quotidien est ici
mais les vrais cesser merci c'est un
vrai ça c'est un sujet
quand vous êtes moi je quand j'ai été
nommé ministre
sarkozy par nicolas sarkozy et
j'étais le
neuvième ministre de l'outre-mer en dix
ans
j'avais en face de moi une
administration de grande qualité avec
des gens intelligents bien formés très
dévoués à leur tâche mais je lisais quoi
dans leurs yeux
cause toujours tu seras partie avant
nous et c'était vrai puisque je suis
resté 15 mois et 5 jours j'étais parti
avant lui et eux ils ont fait des belles
carrières regardez quand un ministre est
viré tout son cabinet qui sont des haut
fonctionnaires d'un moment ils sont ils
sont promus
ils sont promus et donc il ya un moment
où le cabinet a un peu envie que le
ministre soit viré pour avoir un job un
peu moins épuisant parce que faire du
cabinet ministériel c'est un énorme
boulot et puis pour avoir des promotions
donc effectivement l'administration
française elle est admirable par sa
formation par son intelligence elle
tient le pays elle fait elle fait que
l'état et on a on a un système étatique
de qualité sauf que elle est beaucoup
plus pérenne que le politique qui lui
est là pour quelques années qu'ils
pensent souvent et trop à sa réélection
qui essaye de marquer des points qui est
qui qui au fond ne fait pas le travail
de fond alors est ce qu'un haut rhin en
jour comme vous l'avez dit qui aura le
courage
peut-être que ça pose la question de nos
institutions peut-être faut-il que
notamment beaucoup plaident pour un
mandat unique de président de la
république non renouvelable pour libérer
celui qui est en place pour faire le
boulot mais
même ce système là regardez jacques
chirac a été élu face à jean marie le
pen avec 83% il savait que c'était son
dernier mandat qui n'avait plus de
soucis de réélection quand il était élu
face à jean marie le pen moi je m'étais
dit à ce moment là jacques chirac il va
faire la révolution il va dire je n'ai
plus de soucis de l'élection j'ai été
élu à 83% je suis légitime on va on va
réformer le pays et il a fait tout le
contraire il s'est dit tant mieux et il
est passé sous les fourches caudines et
son dernier septennat était un septennat
sarkozy parlait du du des rois fainéants
ce qui était très cruel et injuste mais
ça n'a pas été un sénat un septennat de
réformes alors qu'ils avaient l'occasion
politique de réformer le pays de
remettre à plat le système donc
effectivement il va falloir un moment
soit qu' un choc et dans l'histoire on
apprend que souvent les changements de
système où les évolutions de systèmes se
font sur des chocs soi qui est à jour
une conjonction ou y ait quelqu'un qui
dit je met tout sur la table et on fait
le boulot je décrivais pardon de faire
la publicité pour ce livre sorti à
l'entente mais dans le voka l'idée de
dire que un président et lui devrait
dire voilà je vais poser sur la table
des grandes réformes je vais vous les
faire approuver par référendum
si vous les approuver on les met en
oeuvre si vous les approuver pas je m'en
vais vous voulez pas vous voulez pas
tant pis on m'a élu président voulait
pas faire les réformes en v mais est-ce
que c'est pas une vision romanesque est
ce que c'est possible dans une
démocratie d'opinion où l'opinion quand
elle va voter votre toujours pour autre
chose que la question qu'on lui pose
est-ce que c'est crédible ce système là
mais il va bien falloir qu'on trouve
parce que le moyen que fait de changer
d'avis tient la langue française de
faire de la subornation de vote
d'endormir les gens
c'est pas coupable
si ces coupables mais est ce que le
système permet de faire autre chose
aujourd'hui parce que les gens ne
voterai pas pour vous si vous ne le
manquez pas les yeux dans les yeux
est ce que si vous dites aux gens je ne
vais pas pouvoir tout faire je pense
qu'à des grands défauts c'est marrant
parce que depuis que j'ai quitté la vie
politique je réfléchis beaucoup à ces
questions même des grands défauts c'est
que vraiment peut-être non
je réfléchissais avant mais à d'autres
choses mais je réfléchis et je réfléchis
concernant l'élection présidentielle
comme je n'ai jamais été candidat on est
on est assez tranquille et candide et un
jour je n'ai pas vocale et les pousser
un candidat je ne le soutiendrai sans
doute un candidat je ne sais pas mais
mais je ne sais pas aujourd'hui je suis
libre je n'appartiens plus aucun parti
politique tant que don car techniquement
je ne vais plus de cartes partis
politiques de l'unique but de cotisation
et je ne peux plus je ne financent plus
aucun parti possible in fine ans et plus
avec votre celi en votre parti je ne
financent plus aucun parti politique sur
ce sujet et donc fait du bien pour lui
bien ni mal c'est notre vie sur ce sujet
mais toujours politique non
tout est politique
vos questions sont politiques tout est
politique et les français sont
passionnés par la politique qu'ils
adorent la police à la politique mais
messi la politique c'est la gestion d'un
site et se faire enfumer toute la
journée ces passages politiquement
france d'accord ceci si vous avez cette
analyse des choses
se faire enfumer toute la journée non
c'est pas la vérité est ce que les
thématiques la journée on ne se faire
enfumer attaque là maintenant les
politiques sont pas des enfumeurs
professionnels jeu et sculpteur d'air
chaud des brasseurs de fumer je je je
suis pas
je suis pas d'accord avec vous je pense
que c'est votre droit oui mais bien sûr
mais qu'est ce qu'il disait macron
désaccords politiques non je vais vous
dire pourquoi je suis pas d'accord ce
que macro et à surfer un peu sur cette
idée là quand il a après avoir été élu
quand il a présenté ses candidats vous
souvenez du la façon dont il a été
chercher des gens de la société civile
des gens qui n'étaient pas oui oui vous
ceux qui ne regardent me vois pas que
vous faites comme ça c'est vrai je vois
que vous faites comme ça ça n'a pas
marché et ça n'a pas marché et pourtant
c'était des braves gens c'étaient des
chefs d'entreprise c'était des gens qui
étaient impliqués dans la vie qui sont
venus avec leur bonne volonté avec
l'idée de dire on va changer les choses
moi j'ai le souvenir je vais t'aider
j'ai été réélu dans cette danse est dans
cette mandature me suis parti un an
après et j'ai vu tous ses parlementaires
plein de bonne volonté plein de plein
dans vie et au bout de six mois depuis
moins d'un an on peut pas ça marche pas
le système est trop compliqué on
n'arrive pas à faire les choses donc
l'idée de dire il nous enfume ils nous
mentent volontairement je pense que
c'est très rassurant pour ne pas se
poser les questions sur est-ce que c'est
pas plus grave que ça je pense que c'est
plus grave je pense que cette
institutionnels je pense que c'est un
système qui est un système qui est
devenu vermoulu qu'est devenu trop
compliqué que le politique en est
l'expression la plus insupportable aux
yeux de ce que vous me dites sur ce
sujet mais qu'on a quand même besoin de
politiques on a quand même besoin d'une
démocratie qu'on a quand même besoin de
gens qui s'impliquent et que la solution
de sortie de tout ça ce sera sans doute
à un moment encore une fois je me répète
pardon mais où un événement ou un homme
qui prendra la main et sans doute une
transformation institutionnelle
je rejoins l'idée dire que la vème
république qu'elle est hors d'âge
d'ailleurs le général de gaulle à mon
sens ce qui était un pragmatique
n'aurait pas gardé soixante ans après
les mêmes institutions et qu'il faudra
re poser à plat un système
institutionnel plus simple une fiscalité
plus compréhensible un système social
plus efficace une répartition des
pouvoirs un peu plus soft sans doute des
avantages pas seulement politique parce
que les politiques on a beaucoup rogner
les avantages qu'ils pouvaient avoir
les maisons de fonction des préfets des
recteurs tous les moyens qu'ils sont mis
au service de l'administration les
chauffeurs les voitures etc à cette
classe intermédiaire entre le
fonctionnaire lambda qui gagnent mal sa
vie elle politique et dans la lumière il
ya toute une classe intermédiaire qui
vit sur le système et qui en vit très
bien du système faudra se poser toutes
ces questions vivent très bien parce
qu'il fonctionnaires qui viennent plus
que demba ba moi quand j'étais ministre
j'avais aiguille fonctionnaires dans mon
ministère qui gagnait plus que moi oui
bien sûr combien
à l'époque je ne sais plus moi j'étais
je vais avoir onze mille euros je crois
brute nette avec le coiffeur chouf non
non je n'avais pas de coiffeur je
n'avais pas de javel à chauffeur et
j'étais logé dans le ministère sur ce
sujet mais je crois qu'ils avaient oui
c'est tout lui aux fonctionnaires qui
avait treize quatorze mille qui étaient
logés aussi qu'elle vaut aussi des
moyens sur ce sujet tout ça il sans
toutefois nommer tout ça étant issu
d'une autre époque et et l'adaptation à
l'époque moderne elle doit elle doit se
faire beaucoup plus vite sur ces sujets
là alors on focalise sur le politique
c'est normal c'est lui qui assume c'est
lui à qui on donne le pouvoir je
n'aurais moi je suis mis les piles et
gbp unis suivront des décisions de merde
il est par exemple assez décousu il est
gagné par l'élection qu'un homme est
d'accord ça c'est ça c'est l'ultime il
est puni par injection il revient à
chaque fois nous bat sarkozy veut il est
revenu à jean vous lui là il a quelques
grosses casseroles là mais ces résidus
l'innocent et bah j'en sais rien mais
que vous voulez que je sache que je suis
pas juge moi je lis les journaux les
médias esquisses réalisées dans les
journaux ces soutiens ça se tient pas
aucune idée non mais aucune idée si ça
se tient aussi ça se tient pas quand on
entend ces avocats quand on l'entend lui
on se dit bon ça se tient pas il ya une
espèce de montage qui lui qui est
vraiment là on veut l'étrier faut dire
qu'avec les juges il a été il a il a été
costaud il et il sait pas il en a dit
sur les juges donc on pourrait penser
que le corps de la justice veuille se
venger aussi et puis quand on lit
d'autres on se dit ah oui bon voilà
c'est en ce sens qu'on a besoin d'une
justice pour faire l'équilibré entre
tout ça moi je ne sais pas le juger à la
place des juges quand je lis certains
journaux je veux dire oh la la il a dû
en faire quand je les coûts de pluie ou
j'entends ses avocats je veux dire voilà
là bas qu'est ce qu'il en prend plein la
gueule ben je sais pas faire le juste
milieu de tout ça
le pire crasse le truc le plus sordide
que vous y avez pu voir durant votre
carrière de politique qu'est ce qu'est
ce que vous appelez comme crasse des
trucs des gens qui se gavent des parties
fines des détournements
des gens qui devaient pas être payé si
jaloux des choses comme ça honnêtement
j'ai jamais non non je n'ai jamais vu de
pierre de pires crasses comme ça va j'ai
jamais vu de j'ai entendu des choses
j'ai lu des choses dans les journaux on
a vu exploser des affaires qui s'appelle
cahuzac qui s'appelle d'autres et c'est
mémé que mémé mais y avait il n'y a pas
de visibilité de l'intérieur j'ai pas vu
des trucs que je me fais des robes à la
quelle horreur qui combine que tout le
monde connaît non non je ne cherche pas
mais enfin ça qu'est ce que vous appelez
petites combines ckoi petites combines
par exemple se fait rembourser des trucs
qui sont pas dû acheter son qg de
campagne avec des fonds publics
faire payer une assistante qui est pas
son assistante qui est sa femme sa fille
sa petite fille maman ma femme par
exemple à travailler pour moi et c'était
son métier je les rencontrais dans la
politique on s'est connus de la
politique elle étaient collaboratrices
mme un ancien premier ministre et
communistes n'ont pas communiste et la
prêtrise d'un d'un ancien premier
ministre on s'est connus on sait on
s'est mariés et naturellement l'a trahie
et moi à l'époque où ça ne choquer
personne et après quand ça a choqué tout
le monde elle a pu travailler avec moi
sur ce sujet mais elle a fait du boulot
il était là tous les jours elle pose
avec man donc
jeunes comment vous quel regard vous
allez sur la sphère près d'îlots de
fillon
qu'on juge avec les yeux de vingt ans
après ce qui était accepté même si ça
n'était pas acceptable 20 ans avant
et que la pratique
de de faire travailler ces conjoints ses
proches est une partie
extraordinairement répandu dans la vie
politique pendant des années jusqu'à ce
que ça devienne insupportable
et que c'est un vrai problème avec une
société qui avance très vite sur ces
exigences et aux deux juges et le passé
avec les yeux du futur cirque et l'usoc
l affaire cahuzac le blond je n'ai pas
de comptes dans les paradis fiscaux
ouais c'est les yeux dans les yeux mais
qu'est ce qui l'a poussé à dire ça moi
je j'ai connu la prison j'ai je sais pas
j'ai connu c'était un
garçon
bryant qui avait beaucoup de morts gain
qui traitait pas les gens ce n'était pas
un humanisme et moi j'étais il était
dans la majorité de l'époque j'étais
dans l'opposition
bon c'était mais qu'est ce qui l'a
poussé à dire ça je sais pas je ne sais
pas j'ai pas des analyses mais vous
savez ces questions-là sur les jeux de
pouvoir sur les ambitions sur les
mensonges sur tout ça dès qui a pouvoir
que ce soit dans le monde de
l'entreprise dans le monde de la haute
administration dont tout l'est dans le
monde des médias dans le monde du cinéma
de la culture des qui a pouvoir yat il
ya tous ces jeux là la différence de la
politique c'est que c'est insupportable
parce qu'il s'agit d'argent public et
que c'est d'autant plus insupportable
parce que c'est sous la loupe des médias
en permanence et que le miroir
grossissant il est permanent c'est à
dire que si des conflits entre grands
chefs de service dans les hôpitaux
faisait tous les la une des médias comme
des conflits entre politiques les gens
se diraient mais nos grands chirurgiens
sont devenus des fous furieux qu'est ce
que c'est que ces méthodes là ce que je
veux dire c'est que le côté public et
c'est tant mieux c'est ça le sind et
démocratie le côté public de la vie
politique fait que ce genre de pratique
et se fait sur la scène au vu et au su
de tout le monde effectivement ça donne
une image épouvantable le jour on
s'intéresse autant aux débats entre
grands patrons entre grand syndicaliste
ou entre grands producteurs de cinéma et
qu'on met le projecteur dessus et que et
que tout éclate on va se dire que tous
les milieux des lieux l'insupportable là
vous dédouanez l'enjeu des douanes
bassidjis et je ne les donnerai à chacun
a sa part donné pas responsables j'ai
pas dessaisir dont j'ai jamais dit on
n'est pas raison on a les médias tout le
temps sur le paul et ce n'est pas
difficile où je n'ai pas des finances
qui nous fraude est tranquille devant
l'assemblée nationale il lâche ça c'est
quoi ça c'est insupportable
comme tous ceux qui mentent publiquement
sur une sur une sur une sécurité plus
menteur
c'est à dire c'est qu'ils qu'il est le
gouvernement qui était le plus menteur
aucune je suis incapable de vous dire ça
et je pense que le mensonge est
malheureux
j'ai une petite idée non je suis
incapable de vous dire qui est le plus
menteur ou le moins menteur j'ai pas
gpad j'ai pas testé ça mais que le
mensonge
n'est pas seulement réservé aux
politiques et j'ai pas dit ça vous
pouvez pas dire que je des douanes que
je dis c'est pas grave c'est pas ça non
non c'est une caricature barça vous
rendez peut-être pas content des gains
l'extérieur c'est bien si ça ressemble à
ça je veux couper ça parce que c'est pas
vrai parce que l'homme politique il a sa
responsabilité
on lui donne du pouvoir il doit être
exemplaire il doit faire le boulot ils
doivent faire avancer les choses moi
j'ai été pendant 22 ans maire d'une
commune répit sur ce sujet et j'ai
conscience de ça mais vous me demandez
mon témoignage d'anciens politique je
vous explique aussi que d'essayer
d'apporter quelque chose d'équilibré
c'est peut-être quelque chose de
centristes c'est tellement facile de
dire qu'il y aurait en france 577 à
l'eau à l'assemblée 325 salle au sénat
40 salles au gouvernement et qui si on
les change et ça irait beaucoup mieux
bah si c'était vrai ce serait
merveilleux malheureusement c'est pas
vrai c'est plus compliqué que ça c'est
plus compliqué que ça et d'ailleurs y
compris quand vous changez une partie
importante des sénateurs des députés
d'aidé des gouvernements
le système perdure c'est bien qu'il ya
un problème de système plus qu'un
problème de personne ce qui veut pas
dire que le problème de personne
n'existe pas mais ce qui veut dire qu'il
faut pas non plus caricaturer pour dire
qu'il ya pas de problème de système il
faut qu'on se pose les bonnes questions
vous dites que je suis en train qui ont
été tuées danger salive ou a tenu bon
j'ai pas dit que vous caricaturez mais
je ne veux pas le côté c'est l'ancien
politique qui défend les politiques il
accuse les médias et dit qu'ils sont
coupables de rien c'est pas vrai je suis
pas sur cette voie là je reconnais la
réalité des choses mais je ne veux pas
être non plus ceux qui disent les
politiques sont des [__] et si on
avait je ne sais pas qui à la place
c'est vrai beaucoup mieux parce que à ma
connaissance il ya aucun système dans le
monde parfait et aucun système qui est
qui est remarquable donc il faut qu'on
se pose les bonnes questions il faut que
les français se regardent aussi dans un
miroir pour savoir quelle est leur part
de responsabilité que c'est tellement
facile de dire c'est pas moi c'est les
autres moi je dis j'ai ma part de
responsabilité quand j'ai fait de la
politique j'ai assumé un certain nombre
de choses un certain nombre d'erreurs ou
un certain nombre de choses qui m'ont
valu de sortir du gouvernement mais je
ne regrette pas ce que j'ai fait sur ce
sujet
il faut aussi avoir le courage et
peut-être l'intelligence de dire
regardons tous mettons tout sur la table
c'est si c'était si simple vous rendez
compte aller 900 députés
40-40
ministre 300 fonctionnaires vont changer
tout ça le pays va mieux ben
malheureusement c'est plus grave que ça
pis donc il est ainsi le pays il est là
actuellement dans un état de dépression
qui est lié en avant avant ce que ça
c'est un épiphénomène
ouais enfin c'est un épiphénomène qui
est face à un phénomène je vais pas si
on peut le on peut le balayer comme ça
mais c'est quand même un phénomène
s'était quand même anticiper tout le
monde savait que ça allait nous tomber
sur le coin du nez pour moi je le savais
pas si vous vous le saviez mais je ne
savais pas en tout cas il y avait il y
avait effectivement des rapports qui ont
été déterrés de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé où apparemment on prévoyait
une maladie qui un jour pouvait faire ça
enfin comme toutes les choses
catastrophiques qu'on prévoit on pense
toujours qu'elles vont pas arriver sur
politique qui dit hausse à eau paris v
oui ou c'est le citoyen qui se dit
maintenant j'aurai pas de cancer je vais
continuer à fumer à boire et puis quand
ça lui arrive je dis ah ben merde si
j'avais su pourtant on lui avait dit là
aussi le politique c'est pas c'est pas
le feu nucléaire c'est pas une
administration moelleux le particulier
il fume c'est sa responsabilité
quand le policier non c'est juste pour
voir la mécanique qui consiste à dire
quand on vous annonce quelque chose de
grave vous y croyez pas forcément sur ce
sujet et vous regardez quand roselyne
bachelot avait commandé trop de vaccins
on lui est tombé sur la gueule l'ancien
vraiment c'est du gâchis d'argent public
donc c'est aussi la société du paradoxe
que j'évoquais c'est à dire que et
pourtant elle avait eu raison de
commander des vaccins parce qu'elle
avait une prudence surtout l'opposition
qu'il était tombé sur le plateau nous
importer les journalistes et les médias
et la presse et l'opinion publique en
disant à la dépenser trop d'argent pas
que l'opposition sur ce sujet et donc
elle a été voué aux gémonies sur ce
sujet pour qu'on s'aperçoive quelques
années après qu'elle avait été prudente
quand sur ces questions là donc il y
avait bien sûr il ya la responsabilité
du politique il ya sur cette pandémie je
pense que
ce qui dirait on savait on aurait dû sur
cette question et
tout le monde savait que ça allait venir
ça me semble sion introduction au siècle
des menaces jacques blamont aux éditions
odile jacob
fondateur du printemps social français
mais je ne nie pas que des gens et des
harkis de morceaux plus que des sachants
et des savants et prévenus sauf que la
liste des catastrophes qui sont
annoncées dans des livres très
importants sont multiples et que le
politique qui peut pas se dire je vais
prendre tout ça à la vérité s'il
organisait juillet en fonction de sa
question tôt c'est une question de
prisme de lecture c'est une question de
vision court termiste du politique c'est
une vision après moi le déluge c'est
quoi c'est une question dans
c'est une question de rassurance
et que le politique
et compte tenu de la force de sa parole
il ne peut pas jouer l'euro chose de
sympa oui de la forte parce qu'il est
médiatique parce que la force ça c'est
un votre époque que ça
parce que vous pensez que quand le
président de la république s'exprime aux
copains un ministre s'exprime sa parole
elle est plus forte que comme c'est la
mienne aujourd'hui qui ne fait plus de
politique je peux c'est sûr que ça en
tout cas elle est entendue el adha
puissance on reste encore sous le j'ai
pas dit la qualité de sa parole jeudi sa
force non mais j'ai dit ça force qui est
très entendus sur ce sujet là et donc
effectivement le aussi si vous regardez
toute la littérature tous les gens qui
très intelligemment prévoit des choses
catastrophiques qui peut arriver non non
j'en ai pas comme ça à l'esprit mais il
ya il ya des gens comme l'ancien
ministre
je cherche au nom de l'écologie voilà il
coachait kiki qui dit des choses en
disant voilà faut prévoir le système va
vous collapse et et ces raisons il
apparaît donc je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas et et si j'ose dire pour mon confort
intellectuel je voudrais qu'il n'est pas
raison et pour mes enfants je voudrais
qu'ils n'apparaissent même de confondre
les tue non c'est un problème de non
mais là je suis citoyen moi je sur ce
sujet et et le politique n'apprend pas à
c'est à dire je ne sais pas
le politique il est censé tout savoir
donc on lui pose une question vous devez
savoir ben sidi je ne sais pas de qui se
sait que celui-là pourquoi les élus
puisqu'il sait pas
vous allez votez pour qui aux prochaines
élections je vais voter pour qui aux
prochaines élections ben je nomme je ne
sais pas quel soin des candidats j'ai du
mal à vous répondre en tout cas je sais
pour qui je ne voterai pas je ne voterai
pas pour les extrêmes ni pour monsieur
mélenchon ni pour madame le pen après
entre les deux mélenchon c'est un
extrême j'ai
moi j'aime bien jean luc mélenchon pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que on
se connaît mais il était ancien ministre
et que on s'est croisé enfin on se
connaît c'est quelqu'un que je que j'ai
appris à connaître il a été élu de
l'essonne moi j'étais élu de
seine-et-marne enfin même si on a une
différence d'âge que à l'assemblée il a
toujours été très courtois avec moi y
compris quand je présidais les séances
de l'assemblée nationale et que je
reconnais chez jean luc mélenchon une
puissance culturelle une une capacité
d'expression une analyse de la société
je ne partage je suis loin de tout
partager mais tout ce qu'il dit n'est
pas à jeter au contraire y est j'ai pas
le côté néo marxiste le côté anti
libérale le côté caricatural de faut
faire payer les riches etc c'est pas moi
je suis à libéral de formation je
partage pas c'est cette analyse
de de gauche alors je sais pas s'il faut
la qualifiait en tout cas néo-marxiste
fait comme ça que je vais l'appeler mais
par contre ce qu'il a dit sur la
puissance maritime de la france est
l'atout que représenterait la puissance
maritime de la france j'ai été ministre
des outre-mer je mesure combien avec 12
kg 12 millions de kilomètres carrés de
zone économique exclusive maritime on a
une puissance maritime et et on n'en
fait rien si on a nommé une ministre de
la mer dans le dernier gouvernement mais
enfin bon je vais pas vu beaucoup de
résultats c'est des atouts qui sont des
atouts français mais je voterai pas pour
jean luc mélenchon je ne voterai pas
pour marine le pen entre ça il ya un peu
de marge on verra jean luc mélenchon est
au 2e tour voter pour jean luc mélenchon
face à qui sa marine le pen ça c'est un
vrai sujet
ça c'est vrai si j'ai en tout cas je
voudrais pas marine le pen
voulait pas dire que vous allez voter
mélenchon je préférerais qu'il soit pas
au 2e tour pour m'offrir un choix plus
en rapport avec ce que je souhaite
vous êtes libéral c'est ça veut dire
quoi libéral
ça veut plus rien dire
ça veut peut-être pas dire la même chose
que ça ne voulait dire
au siècle dernier
mais ça veut dire que je suis pour la
libre entreprise la concurrence que je
suis attaché aux libertés individuelles
que je suis pour un état qui ne viennent
pas empiéter en permanence sur les
libertés individuelles
si ça veut dire encore des choses dans
ce dossier qu'est ce que vous en parle
dans la régulation des marchés
financiers la régulation des marchés
financiers je leur libération
c'est pas libérale de réguler les
marchés financiers et libéralisme veut
pas dire absence de régulation
la liberté elle elle peut être régulés
c'est l'interdiction qui est mauvaise et
pour réguler les marchés financiers il
nous manque un outil
du courage non ça s'appelle un outil à
la dimension des marchés financiers qui
sont internationaux et qui dépasse les
frontières et au fond des grands sujets
j'évoquais tout à l'heure vous m'avez
vous m'avez m'avait coupé dans mon élan
mais quand hollande disait vous allez
voir la finance on va la maîtriser mais
l'homme politique devra avoir le courage
de dire à l'échelon des pays la finance
je peux rien ça me dépasse ça passe au
dessus
c'est ça dépasse les états regardez
comment on court après les gaffes à pour
essayer de leur faire payer des impôts
quelque part on voit bien que ça
participe d'ailleurs à ce que l'homme
politique ne soit plus crédible c'est
qu'au fond l'homme politique qui vient
dire aux citoyens votez pour moi j'ai du
pouvoir je vais changer les choses au
fond le citoyen et c'est très bien comme
politique a de moins en mois de pouvoir
et qui court derrière des phénomènes qui
sont mondialisés la mondialisation est
là elle est là mondialisée des
phénomènes après lesquels on court et la
finance elle est devenue mondialisée
vous avez un gouvernement mondial qui
peut juguler la finance non un pays
peut-être une incidence est devenu le
gouvernement mondial non mais peut-être
mais peut-être qu'on a envahi le
luxembourg avec nos chars alors je ne
sais pas mais je vois pas je le
luxembourg en matière financière
l'europe a quand même passé des gros
coup de rabot donc je pense que les
sources de la finance folle elles vont
plutôt être dans l'angleterre
et sortie de l'europe et des douanes et
des règles européennes que au luxembourg
connaissent et le luxembourg je ne suis
jamais allé mais j'ai rencontré à
plusieurs reprises le premier ministre
du luxembourg mais je n'y suis jamais
allé
on sait combien de temps
oui il faut arrêter de vous frotter oui
c'est ça j'ai bien compris que c'est ça
faisait du bruit donc c'était ça traduit
peut-être quelque chose oui que vous
allez penser qu'il faudrait un peu de
crème ses saints n'ont peut-être que je
suis pas chemakh y est où je sais pas
donc des stress qui on va peut-être
monter le niveau là non c'est vous qui
pilotait si vous allez trop moi je sais
c'est je respirerai plus donc vous
m'aurez perdu nous est le 6ème général
de villiers au deuxième tour face à jean
luc mélenchon
[Rires]
j'écris des romans donc c'est bien mais
je ne suis pas posé cette question mais
je vous promets je viendrai vous dire ce
que je ferais mais je serais bien embêté
parce que vous pensez du général
deauville je pense que je n'aime pas les
donneurs de leçons et il est donné
qu'elles le sont
j'ai j'ai trouvé que son attitude au
moment de l'élection d' emmanuel macron
et sa démission sur le thème comment
apolitique a osé me parlez moi chef
d'état major des armées qui n'est
d'ailleurs jamais gagné de guerre
puisqu'il n'a plus guère sur ce sujet
imaginez parce que moi je considère que
l'armée les armées sont à grand corps
que je suis très respectueux des
militaires mais qu'elles sont soumises à
l'autorité politique et que le politique
quand il décide l'armée à l'aube et quel
que soit le politique l'armée doit obéir
et j'ai trouvé son attitude m'a gêné oui
à titre personnel chance c'est de la
sécession
je sais pas c'est de l'orgueil à mon
avis
ça et français non c'est quoi être
français pour vous
c'est peut-être être orgueilleux oui
peut-être c'est vous qui me l'avait sauf
et être français c'est sans doute je
sais pas parce que je veux pas faire un
truc lyrique n'a le temps vous pouvez
chanter si vous voulez
être français je pense que c'est c'est
partager une histoire c'est moi je suis
très amateur d'histoire j'ai écrit
plusieurs romans historiques donc je
pense que on est on est pas on n'est pas
français si on s'empare pas de
l'histoire je vais pas dit on peut on
peut venir d'ailleurs être français pour
s'emparer de l'histoire de france pour
pour s'emparer de ce qui fait nos
racines et qui fait nos racines
l'histoire c'est la lettre de guy môquet
c'est quoi c'est tout à la fois c'est
clovis c'est napoléon c'est guy môquet
c'est de gaulle c'est simone veil s'est
tous tout ce qui forge au fond ce qui
est notre fierté est peut-être notre
orgueil disent les étrangers en disant
des français vous êtes orgueilleux mais
qui est aussi le fait qu'un pays qui
aujourd'hui n'est plus un très grand
pays en matière de démographie dans le
monde reste un pays qui compte encore
autour de la planète et et quand on va
dans n'importe quel pays du monde est
français c'est pas rien
c'est pas mal ça va être français ce
n'est pas rien
français c'est un état d'esprit
non
pas être allemand c'est aussi un état
d'esprit j'imagine donc je suis pas sûr
qu'il faille se différencier comme ça en
tout cas je pense que juste pas sûr
qu'on soit une nation
et que au fond et prédation je suis pas
sûr qu'on soit une nation comme d'autres
pays sont une nation dit je pense que on
est un état d'abord et que l'état et et
c'est d'ailleurs un des grands problèmes
de ce qui se passe actuellement avec les
formes de défaillance de l'état sur la
gestion des masques etc sur beaucoup de
choses c'est que c'est que c'est que
c'est poli défaillance ça s'appelle
d'incompétence crasse très bien ok on
peut avoir un vocabulaire en mai trois
grandes plus d'accord n'est compétent un
charge accord mais j'appelle les jeunes
mois chacun appelle le chat comme mieux
moi vous vous appelez les gros bateaux
moi je lé petit chat la défaillance
incompétence crasse que vous voulez de
l'état mais coûte cher parce qu'au fond
sans doute que l'état est un des
éléments fédérateurs de la france fasse
de fonctionnaires de fonctionnaires
c'est ça c'est ça qui est fédérateur non
l'état au sens où depuis
plus de deux siècles depuis colbert je
pense on a un carnet l'état comme étant
d'être suprême
plutôt moins on respire
j'ai plutôt mara
et je suis plutôt phuc fouquet et
colbert alors pourquoi plutôt marrant
j'ai pas c'est l'excès de robespierre
c'est
gégé comme ça le sentiment mais
peut-être que ceux qui vont face chez
qu'est ce que je dis vont me démentir
que robespierre était plus sanguinaires
vicas
sanguinaire est-ce qu'on va repasser par
cet épisode houleux politique aura
tellement provoqué le peuple français
que nous vieux démons vont se réveiller
c'est possible
c'est possible c'est possible que les
démons française se réveille c'est
possible qu'on aille vers un choc de
type entre guillemets révolutionnaire
même s'il faut manier ce mot avec
prudence sur ce sujet
c'est pas impossible est-ce que vous
pensez que notre est incertain
d'ailleurs paris là dessus certains
espèrent là dessus vous parliez de
mélenchon il espère la révolte du peuple
mélenchon l'a reçue quand on vous dit
que quand on écoute la perception des
médias sur mélenchon ou l'impression de
ça y est c'est un trou ce qui ce lead
mista soit fit son mélenchon je pense
que c'est un gain qui capable de
respecter sa parole c'est à dire que
s'il ne respecte pas son programme il
sait qu'il se fracasser les genoux et
que et que i qu il assumera
j'ai jamais dit le contraire d'accord un
mois j'ai dit que son programme néo
marxiste n'était pas ma tasse de thé et
deuxièmement une des voix qui l'espère
pour prendre le pouvoir et une voix
qu'ils ne seraient pas une voie purement
démocratique mais qui pourrait être
d'essayer de surfer sur une vague
révolutionnaire sur ça ce qui est
d'ailleurs un peu le défaut de la gauche
souvenez-vous ou souvenons nous de
mitterrand en mai 68 se disant le
montant est venu je vais prendre le
pouvoir par
grâce à la révolution du peuple donc
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai voulu dire
bon
revenons à nos moutons
nos hommes politiques non a dit notre
administration ça commence à cafouiller
un peu il ça se voit maintenant ça se
voit ça se sent les masques ont montré
leur degré d'incompétence
le mensonge politique est arrivé sur la
place publique qui sont fait prendre la
main dans le sac beaucoup des basses que
machin moi je ne sais pas le mettre vous
avez été porte-parole de quelque chose à
l'ump ouais c'est quelque chose oui
c'est quelque chose n'a pas c'était
quelque chose non c'était quelque chose
c'était un parti politique maintenant
c'est plus rien abba l'ump ça n'existe
plus appelle les républicains c'est
pareil bah c'est
un peu plus de cent mille personnes qui
se mobilisent pour pour essayer de
porter une idée collective lui dise et
quoi lui dei c'est un peu plus tôt c'est
un peu plus de dix mille personnes qui
se mobilisent pour porter moi aussi ça
c'est le côté un peu aussi pertinent
qu'un filet d'eau tiède c'est quoi c'est
une socialiste
c'est je ne sais pas comparer ça lui
dise est fondée sur l'idée d'une droite
européenne convaincue
écolo est très ouverte sur les sujets de
société
elle écoute on va bientôt parler
d'europe
revenons revenons un petit peu sur notre
notre pays
on est en cours de tiers-mondisation
on a une classe de politique qui
ressemble plus à une classe de
politiques d'afrique centrale ou de
d'amérique du sud ça commence à se voir
la récession c'est un peu comme la mère
qui est-ce qui se retire on est en train
de voir qui est en short
la france va ou dans les cinq ans à
venir
je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas je ne savais pas parce
que vous ne pouvez pas tabler sur les
politiques qui nous dirigent pas ce que
vous faites pas confiance à notre mode
d'administration parce que vous
connaissez déjà les paramètres
économiques parce que
ce que vous n'avez pas envie de vous
prononcer non non je j'avais envie de me
prononcer je me prononcerai je vous
dirais j'ai pas envie de me prononcer et
non je ne sais pas sincèrement parce que
je pense que nous sommes à la fin d'un
cycle l'histoire de notre pays
largement d'ailleurs l'histoire de
l'humanité que
le nouveau cycle n'est pas encore
complètement posée et que nous avons un
modèle vieillissant qui peut se traduire
par les propos que vous avez tenus d
institution vieillissante une
organisation administrative
vieillissante un système social fiscal
je vais pas revenir sur ce que j'ai dit
en début d'entretien qui est
vieillissant qui est compliqué qui
datent d'une autre époque quand on pense
que notre constitution date d'il ya plus
de 63 ans aujourd'hui
le monde a changé de façon absolument
conséquente que il ya une exigence de
l'opinion de changer tout ça est à la
fois une frise la frilosité quand il
s'agit de changer les choses c'est à
dire que dès qu'il ya une réforme
peut-être qu'elles sont malmenés
peut-être qu'elles sont mal expliqué
peut-être qu'elles ne sont pas peu
théologique mais des graisses et
pédagogique se dit que vous voulez
réformer quelque chose depuis le
monsieur qui disaient qu'ils dépassent
et pédagogique
jean paul delevoye
ont fait montre les communautés de notre
bon temps mais ce que je veux vous dire
pour répondre à votre question sur les
seins dans les cinq ans qui viennent
j'aurais pas des propos aussi
catégorique que ce que vous évoquez des
comparaisons 6 forte que ce que vous
évoquez sur le tiers-monde et ses
qualités non c'est pas ma vérité c'est
votre vérité c'est une façon d'exprimer
disons que moi je m'exprime des choses
avec peut-être un peu plus de nuances je
vais vous mettre les yeux en face des
trous mais mais mais mais mais vous
semez lions face et j'ai les yeux en
face des trous mais à voir les yeux en
face des trous je ne dis pas qu'on peut
manquer de nuance moi j'aime la nuance
photo n'est pas h et d mais vous vous à
mercuès c'est bien de répéter en geek un
certain nombre de deux dictons qui sont
tous très intéressant mais sur ce sujet
j'ai une vision qui c'est qui gilles
legendre agiles les gens
j'ai une vision qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas aussi aussi aussi
caricaturale que qu'ils veulent mais
parce que je pense qu'on est en voie
qu'on voit des étudiants faire la queue
pour avoir à manger dont des pro pour
l'aimer mais quand on emprunte mais
quand on voit des gens qui sont dans la
rue avec des présidents de la république
et les uns et les autres ont dit c'est
insupportable je vais plus personne dans
la rue sur ce sujet quand on voit vous
vous découvrez la misère celle des
étudiants elle est insupportable mais il
n'est pas plus insupportable que celle
des restaurants du coeur ou de la
croix-rouge ou depuis 20 ans ont nourri
des gens parce que la société a du mal à
le faire va je veux dire que d'un seul
coup on a l'impression de se dire oh la
la c'est insupportable dit d'accord on
est en voiture mais on n'est pas en voie
de tiers-mondisation parce que on soigne
pas ce qu'on vit de plus en plus vieux
parce qu'on a une société ou par rapport
à la société dia 50 ans tous ceux qui
ont vécu la société il ya 50 ou 60 ans
on y vit on vous différemment et on vit
quelque part mieux c'est pour ça que je
n'aime pas les mots excessifs mais mais
mais non mais je voulais reproche panju
la liberté du site de dire que la france
soutient monde y est est-ce que c'est
excessif de dire que là ça dépend ce
qu'on met derrière le mot tiers
mondisation sur ce sujet ça dépend des
définitions des mots sur cette question
là je respecte les visions y compris les
plus fortes comme les vôtres et je veux
garder ma liberté c'est peut-être pour
ça que je suis un libéral d'avoir des
expressions qui soit peut-être moins
brutale et je voudrais répondre à votre
question c'est dans cinq ans il va se
passer quoi sur ce sujet mais je ne sais
pas parce qu'effectivement nous sommes
au bout d'un modèle parce
qu'effectivement il ya et la crise de
l'aco vide est venue accélérer un
phénomène avec de la dépression et de la
colère potentiel façade à ce que vous
évoquez sur ce sujet parce
qu'effectivement les hommes politiques
sont les boucs émissaires de tout ça est
au fond faut bien des boucs émissaires
assumons qu'on ait des boucs émissaires
parce qu'effectivement aussi la société
regarde de regards refuse de regarder
ses défauts individuel c'est à dire que
le collectif l'individu considère que le
collectif va mal mais refuse cet effort
personnel pour dire moi qu'est ce que
j'ai fait
pour essayer de participer à tout ça et
que le monde qui vient est un manque
d'inquiétude du réchauffement climatique
dû aux incertitudes de économique due
aux pressions politiques et religieuses
qui surf sur tout ça pour faire leur
beurre et qu'effectivement il peut
sortir de tout ça ou des urnes ou de la
rue lepire j'espère pour ma part et pour
mes enfants qui sortira le moins pire ou
le meilleur mais il peut sortir le pire
tout est possible
quand on voit un is tille international
écrit un papier comme quoi la france
a effectué des arrestations arbitraires
ça vous fait penser un pays du tiers
monde ou pas
ça me fait penser aux pays qui sont
accusés d'avoir effectué des
des arrestations arbitraires le tout est
de savoir dans quelles proportions je ne
dis pas qu une arrestation arbitraire
est acceptable mais c'est à savoir dans
quelles proportions et est ce que ce
sont des arrestations arbitraires qu'on
aboutit sur un jugement arbitraire et
sur des emprisonnements arbitraires ou
est ce que ce sont simplement les
arrestations arbitraires
voilà je
pense que comparaison n'est par exemple
et que les rapports d'amnesty
international ou des défenseurs des
droits de l'homme sont très importants
ce qui utilisent ces petits proverbe
qu'est-ce qui est utilisé comparaison
n'est pas raison on est d'accord ça vaut
bien il faut appeler un chat d'accord
comme expression on va monter un petit
peu à l'ordre alors mon temps d'accord
les plaies les plaies de guerre sur les
gilet jaune vous fait penser un état
tiers mondiste ou pas ça me fait penser
à aller à des enfin l'épisode des gilets
jaunes et les plaies de guerre sur les
gilets jaunes et les destructions
causées par ceux qui se sont emparés du
combat des gilet jaune pour détruire une
grande ou petite un petit effet de
manche on peint on déplie je sais pas
attendez je
ne jouais pas le journaliste d'honneur
ou ne jouais pas l'interviewer plane
dialectique qui dès qu'il ya quelque
chose je dis qu'il vous convient pas
vous dis ne faites pas un événement je
fais les effets que je veux ou alors je
suis plus libre de dire ce que je veux
donc effectivement au moment dé gilet
jaune j'ai été choqué par les
destructions la violence qu'elle soit
venue de ceux qui sont emparés des gilet
jaune que de ceux il ya débat
parlementaire ce qui prouve quand même
qu'on est un pays qui avance sur ce
sujet il ya un débat actuellement sur ce
qu'on appelait les ailes bd qu'on peut
causer ces blessures et sur lequel
effectivement le pays j'espère va faire
marche arrière parce que la violence de
l'état et elle est encore moins
supportable que que le reste de la
violence mais je vais pas nier pour
autant qu' il y avait un climat de
violence et que au nom des gilets jaunes
on a cassé détruit brûlé et failli tuer
des gens dans des incendies à paris
qu'on a tous à l'esprit ça existe aussi
voilà c'est pas parce que ça dérange que
ça existe pas et ça ne dédouane pas les
ailes bd mais ça existe aussi c'est
peut-être pour ça que je suis centriste
parce que j'ai c'est de ça que vous avez
été politique non non vous pourquoi un
bon revenons revenons à notre question
pourquoi pas ce qu'ont dit les choses
qui ne correspondent pas à ce que vous
pensez je sais que vous m mais vous dans
votre bouche mais moi non plus
j'aurai beaucoup plus de mal que vous
n'en auriez vous d'ailleurs oui parce
que je mâche avant
que des politiques moi je mâche pas là
je vous sens mais les politiques ont un
bon réflexe de déglutition
oui heureusement que quand ils avalent
il avale tranquillement pour voter où ça
se passe bien à chaque fois ouais vous
allez un petit peu plus rugueux que la
moyenne on mais je sais pas ce que c'est
que les politiques d'abord
c'est pas c'est comme si on disait les
interviewer les youtuber les
journalistes les médecins et voilà il ya
des c'est pas belle défense pas mal non
mais c'est vrai les politiques alors si
vous dites les politiques sont des
[__] je me sens pas avoir été de ces
catégories si vous voulez vous dit les
politiques mettent beaucoup de bonne
volonté pour essayer de régler des
problèmes compliqués je suis dans cette
catégorie tout ça il ne soyons pas
caricatural que le conseil
constitutionnel qui valide des comptes
de campagne pourri ça vous fait penser
un pays du tiers-monde ou pas ça me fait
penser si c'est le cas un
dysfonctionnement de la plus haute
autorité judiciaire de notre visite en
un commissaire de police oui ça m'est
arrivé ça sent la pisse pas papa dans
les commissariats 9 mai dans les plus
vieux oui hélas la plupart non oui mais
enfin d'autres ceux qui font ça vous
fait penser que les reconstruire le
commissariat de ma ville j'ai mis 15 ans
pour y arriver je mesure les difficultés
de tous et vous avez fait ce avec vos
petites mains non j'ai fait ça en étant
proche de sarkozy quand il était
ministre d'intérieur et en allant lui
dire c'est le bordel il faut
reconstruire et commissariat de
montreuil quant à nicolas sarkozy on va
prendre notre partenariat avec nicolas
sarkozy quand nicolas sarkozy a fait une
loi sur les chiens méchants c'était du
populisme c'était quoi c'était un vrai
problème en tant que maire je
connaissais pas la loi ça
je peux je ne sais plus quel était le
nom de la loi mais
je peux vous dire pour à l'époque
j'étais maire que c'était ce n'était pas
un problème inexistant
sur les chiens dangereux
parce qu'il n'y avait pas fait une loi
sur les propriétaires
c'est à dire sur les propriétés
chimiques et on joue c'est le
propriétaire qui est dangereux alors ça
c'est un vrai débat
pardon c'est pas un débat
si c'est un vrai débat parce que
certains vous explique que c'est le
propriétaire etc en fonction de la façon
dont ils élèvent au doute et l'élève pas
de chien il est dangereux et d'autres
vétérinaire vous explique qu'il ya des
races de chiens par nature plus
dangereuse que d'autres je ne sais pas
trancher ce débat
quand on voit des infirmières à 1500
euros 1300 euros c'est un pays du
tiers-monde où c'est pas un pays du
tiers-monde dans l'est dans les pays du
tiers-monde ya pas d'infirmières
la bonne voie je l'avais un peu en
galère d'infirmières je voudrais que les
infirmières soient mieux payés je
voudrais et je vais répéter ce que j'ai
dit au début que tout le prélèvement
social qui est prélevé sur la richesse
du pays arrive sur le terrain et ne
fuient pas en route entre le le les
otites prélèvements et l'arrivée sur le
terrain et qu'on puisse payer mieux nos
infirmières qu'on peut aussi mieux
considérer notre personnel de santé mais
dans les pays du tiers-monde n'ya pas
d'infirmières
les trous sur les routes le fait qu' on
commence à voir des forêts dans sur une
route de temps en temps c'est quoi ces
espaces les pesticides ou il ya plus de
sous pour les pesticides ou il ya plus
de techniciens de surface c'est quoi on
doit parler sur la même route à un fan
et sur les routes de seine et marne n'y
a pas de trop sur les routes
françois fillon quand il disait je suis
à la tête d'un pays en faillite c'est
quoi c'était un pays qui était endettée
au delà à baky l'heure qu'il est quatre
cinq six sept fois plus à cause de la
coved oui on a on a un vrai souci de
d'endettement du pays il ya un vrai
débat très politique qui sera sans doute
un des débats de 2022 sur la dette qu'on
a contracté en la rembourse son la
rembourse pas on en fait quoi on la
donne aux générations futures on la met
de côté
il ya un vrai débat politique là pour le
coup il faut qu'on l'a répudié la
découpe un mois je pense qu'il faut
rembourser la dette et qu'il faut
trouver les moyens de rembourser la
dette
notamment en taxant les produits qui
polluent et qui est qu'on importe en
masse je suis un défenseur de made in
france ou étudiants ça je pense qu'un
des moyens de rembourser la dette c'est
sans doute de d'avoir un système de tv
avec kilométrique qui soit un système
qui permette de taxes et
d'une partie de la tva le produit en
fonction du nombre de kilomètres qui
fait entre l'endroit où il est fabriqué
l'endroit où il est vendu et que cet
argent là pourrait servir à rembourser
la dette
vous stockez ou votre épargne moi j'ai
pas d'epargne malheureusement vous voyez
combien en ce moment
c'est très variable ce que je suis en
libéral donc il ya des moments où je
gagne assez bien ma vie à peu près ce
que j'avais quand j'étais députée puis
des moments je gagne beaucoup ma vie
donc c'est françois bayrou qui essaient
de se raccrocher aux branches avec 4000
euros en foyer fiscal c'est la classe
moyenne oui mais là c'est un débat
ouvert la semaine c'était un débat
ouvert par part
françois hollande à partir de quand de
quel moment on est riche on n'est pas
riche qu'est ce qu'être riche pour celui
qui n'a rien et qui n'a que le vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure l'infirmière
qu'à 1500 euros celui qui gagnent 15000
euros il est riche pour celui qui gagne
30 mille euros celui qui gagne quinze
mille euros il est moitié peau vous
faites tout ceci et est très relatif ce
qui est intéressant de voir c'est la
pyramide des rémunérations et moi je
fais partie du duo de cette pyramide et
11% pardon du 01 % à je sais pas si
c'est le 0 1 où s'est hissé au plus mais
je fais partie du haut de cette pyramide
ce qui fait d'ailleurs que je suis taxé
dans mes impôts à près de 40% voilà je
paye des impôts et je suis de haut de
cette pyramide je travaille beaucoup
aussi et j'ai l'impression de voler
personne alors travaillant je parle de
mon activité libérale personnel et pas
de ce que je pouvais toucher à l'époque
où j'étais politique c'était bien moins
important vous faites tout sur votre
comptabilité non j'ai un comptable le
pays combien
400 370 euros par mois
va parler un peu de la france là non je
crois qu'on en a parlé vaut pas mal mais
on peut encore bâle préliminaire 1
c'était les préliminaires mais c'est
parfait
donc vous éviter beaucoup en ce moment
avec une pétition qui est pour un
sauvegarder le drapeau français pour les
entreprises françaises qui produisent en
france c'est ça alors je sais pas si je
m'agite beaucoup ainsi vous agitez
vaches m'agite c'est ce qui me fait le
plaisir d'être invité ce soir chez vous
je sais pas si c'est un plaisir
d'ailleurs on verra à la fin mais
non c'est moi je
je pense que produire en france c'est un
projet de société je pense que notre
pays manque de projets collectifs
que ça fait longtemps que les hommes
politiques recherche le graal qui
pourrait rassembler le pays du plus
modestes aux plus riches du plus
éloignés du monde urbain au plus rurales
autour d'un projet collectif pour
avancer ensemble je pense que produire
en france c'est un projet collectif du
plus modeste qui produira des légumes
dans ce jardin aux plus grands
industriels qui produira des avions d
train de l'ingénieur à l'ouvrier
je crois dans un france des usines je
pense qu'on a commis les politiques mais
aussi le capitalisme a commis une erreur
majeure en pensant qu'on pouvait garder
dans les pays dits occidentaux le design
la recherche l'innovation les ingénieurs
et puis tout le reste ça pouvait partir
dans les pays low cost que c'était pas
grave on a commis une erreur
majeure de la france est le pays
occidental qui sait plus se
désindustrialiser depuis les 40
dernières années oui c'est exactement ce
que je dis on a comme une erreur majeure
qu'on en a payé les conséquences en
termes d'emploi et français oui le pays
la france les politiques qu'ils ont payé
coin ils ont pris leur retraite
tranquille tout ce passe bien ok et
qu'est
le
on a besoin de chapelle expiatoire de
nos fautes collectives donc si vous
voulez me redonner une fois que je me
flagelle dans dix ans c'est ma faute
c'est ma très grande faute ok les
politiques ils vont très bien alors que
le reste va très mal j'essaye d'élever
le débat à vous vouliez l'élever si on
reste si l'ensemble de notre débat c'est
on est un pays envoie thierry mandisa
sion les politiques sont des menteurs et
sont des pourris et cto de leur faute
vous avouerez convard est quand même au
ras des pâquerettes ouais je l'aimerais
j'ajoute encore plus c'est comment on
les rend responsables et j'aimerais
comme on les rend responsables j'ai
d'abord ils sont responsables parce que
tous les cinq ans il passe à la
moulinette d'être élu ou pas rêver mais
c'est une forme de responsabilité sur ce
sujet et puis il ya des outils
judiciaire qui peut quand ils ont dérivé
les rendent responsables et
le passé récent a montré que des
politiques pouvaient finir en prison
même si ça n'est qu'une toute petite
partie ça prouve quand même que la
machine peut fonctionner j'aimerais
qu'on reste sur le produire en france
sur cette idée de mobilisation
collective moi je crois que un des
modèles de développement de notre pays
cessera
une france des usines des ateliers de la
production et jeu quand j'ai quitté
l'assemblée nationale je me suis dit je
vais mener ce combat méline france la
production française des usines des
ateliers des ouvriers de cette france
qui n'est pas la france des villes
qu'est la france des gilets jaunes les
usines elles sont pas dans les
métropoles ou très peu les usines elles
sont dans le milieu rural ou dans le
milieu suburbains les usines c'est celle
qui font vivre les cantons c'est celle
qui font vivre les départements et c'est
pas du tout le choeur des métropoles qui
elles sont marquées par les services par
la distribution est pas parler suscite
et ce combat là je le mène de plusieurs
manières et effectivement je suis très
agacé quand je vois qu'il ya des petits
malins qui se disent les français
veulent acheter des produits français
ils sont ils se disent qu'au fond le
made in france c'est écolo et ses
patriotes ça donne de l'emploi et que ça
fait vivre des usines et qui est des
petits malins qui vendent des produits
et du bleu blanc rouge
alors que les produits sont pas français
et donc cette pétition que ceux qui nous
regardent peuvent signer sur challenge
point org je fais un peu de publicité en
direct et cette pétition elle a pour
vocation de demander comme l'ont fait
les suisses une loi
pour dire que quand on met un drapeau
français sur un produit faut que ce soit
un produit français c'est basique mais
celui-ci sont par exemple non c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont pu faire une loi nous nous
sommes prêts pour ça que j que vous
agitez parce que montebourg il s'agite
et aussi les scilly monte à l'europe il
a dit bon on va faire un peu de
protectionnisme économique en
l'occurrence le ministre allemand de
l'industrie ledit coup de mou quand tu
es bien gentil mais moi si j'avoue que
les porsche elles sont faites à
bratislava sert être compliqué et bien
moi je dis au ministre allemand qui a
dit ça que le xxième siècle sera celui
de la transparence et de la traçabilité
et que s'il veut cacher que les porsche
sont faites à bratislava un jour qui
sera pas fait comme un autre le
consommateur le découvrira et l'âme que
porsche sera morte comme la marque qui
fabriquait vous savez les fameux
lasagnes au bon goût d'italie avec la
viande de cheval qui venaient des pays
de l'est de la sauce tomate qui venaient
de chine et de la pâte qui était fait
holmes
vous avez cité le pays tout à l'heure je
vous ai dit que j'avais jamais visité
le paradis fiscal luxembourg voilà la
pâte et f et au luxembourg la marque
elle en est morte sur ce sujet donc je
pense qu'on n'est que la traçabilité et
la sincérité sur l'origine des produits
sera la grande affaire de la
consommation du 21e siècle l'europe
l'europe écolo que l'europe devrait
avancer à grands pas sur ce sujet vous
devrait devrait alors elle avance à 1027
ça marche ou ça ne marche pas
ça marche pas mais est ce qu'on avait
est ce que mitterrand et kohl avait le
choix quand le mur de berlin s'est
effondré de dire aux pays de l'est a qui
ont chanté depuis des années
libérez-vous du communiste vous verrez
c'est mieux de l'autre côté du mur de
leur dire ah nan mais maintenant que
vous l'avez fait mes enfants n'ont pas
l'europe ce n'est pas pour vous parce
que c'est ça le fond du débat parce que
l'europe a grandi trop vite elle s'est
déséquilibré elle n'a pas adapté ses
institutions à une europe qui était
bâtie pour être à 15 ou 17 et qui est
passé à 27 mais c'est bien parce qu'il
ya eu un phénomène politique et que là
on a eu deux dirigeants helmut kohl et
françois mitterrand
qui ont dit venez et on a déséquilibré
le système et l'europe elle s'est
arrêtée à cause de ça et l'europe elle
ne fonctionne plus à cause de ça
aujourd'hui donc moi je suis un européen
convaincu parce que quand je regarde le
monde je me dis la france à 60 millions
on pense pas on pèse pas lourd par
rapport aux 250 millions d'américains au
milliard à quelques de chinois à l'inde
etc mais mais mais l'europe il faut il
faut aujourd'hui ça ne marche plus ça
c'est vrai il 80 millions d'euros ils
peuvent plus bon ils passent plus
économiquement sur ce sujet même si il
n'y a jamais rien de définitif sur cette
question mais il paye quoi on réforme
l'europe on réforme pas l'europe on sort
de l'europe bah on a trois solutions
solutions on reste comme ça voilà on a
un machin ça fait des petits pas mais on
n'avance pas mais c'est possible que je
dis pas que c'est mon choix mais on a
trois solutions de e on va en arrière
chaque pays ferme sur lui c'est un
immense
exit de tous les pays pourquoi vous
dites refermer mais je vais vous
présenter ça avec un vocabulaire négatif
parce que parce que quand vous êtes sur
ap vous avez bien vu ce qui s'est passé
avec l'angleterre sont bien renfermer
derrière leur chanteur
ils ont remis des barrières du
protectionnisme et quand vous allez en
angleterre c'est seul le protectionnisme
le protectionnisme c'est les contraintes
que vous mettez aux frontières oui alors
soit vous les montées aux frontières de
l'europe vous les mettez aux frontières
des nations
c'est pour ça que je dirais renfermer
sur ces sujets et soit on va vers cette
voie là soit troisième solution on
réorganise le système ça veut dire qu'il
faut remettre tout à plat qu'il faut
travailler avec les pays qui sont les
plus proches des uns des autres et qui
peuvent être intégrés c'est les fameux
projet d'europe à plusieurs étages à
plusieurs vitesses avec des politiques
qui sont très intégrés pour les uns et
pas pour les autres moi je plaide pour
un truc sur l'europe et quand j'ai d une
chose qui me semblerait être un
déclencheur un truc bête basique aussi
bête que d'interdire le drapeau français
pour des produits qui sont pas français
les bases un truc m'équipe d'une
puissance absolue moi je voudrais que
lorsqu on vote pour les députés
européens que on appellent tous les
européens à venir choisir leurs
parlementaires européens en même temps
on vote pour un président de l'union
européenne qui soit élu au suffrage
universel des européens parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe elle a pas de
visage y a pas de responsable et la
présidente de la commission européenne
qui est mise en cause aujourd'hui sur
les vaccins elle est nommée n'est pas
élu alors elle est validée par le
parlement il ya un procès ce qui s'est
un peu améliorée dans le temps mais moi
je pense que si on avait le courage de
se dire si on veut faire l'europe on
élit des parlementaires européens et en
même temps le président de la commission
pas en lui donnant plus de pouvoir mais
il est élu et aujourd'hui on voit bien
que il ya des partis politiques qui sont
devenus européen le
le oui sont tous dans des alliances
européennes il n'ya pas de parti
politique ils se sont tous regroupés
pour conter au parlement européen eh
bien je pense qu'on changerait les
choses parce qu'on donnerait un
responsable une incarnation et le
président élu de la commission
européenne par les européens il aurait
la capacité de tirer son bilan de dire
j'ai fait j'ai bien fait j'ai pas bien
fait et c'est je pense que ça pourrait
changer beaucoup de choses pour aller de
l'avant en matière européenne bien sûr
c'est une proposition que nous avons
fait à certaines reprises à l'époque où
je m'occupais de politique qui trouve
beaucoup de freins y compris chez les
présidents de chacun des pays qui se
disent mais on veut pas un super
président plus légitime que nous mais si
on veut faire avancer l'europe peut-être
que cette mesure là je dis pas tout seul
mais ce serait déclencheur symbolique
pour changer la donne
la turquie dans l'europe moi j'ai
toujours été favorable à l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'europe je vous ai partie
des rares qui est dans ma famille
politique était favorable je me suis
fait pourrir la tête pire qu'avec vous
par nicolas sarkozy et d'autres kim a
commencé à voler à la bombe alors là
c'est encore gentiment bas ça va donc je
me suis fait peur et pire la tête par
nicolas sarkozy à l'époque qui était
très très anti entrée de la turquie je
pense que maintenant c'est trop tard je
pense qu'on a amusé le peuple turc
pendant des années en lui disant vous
allez venir vous allez venir et que en
fermant brutalement la porte de l'union
européenne à la turquie on a créé une
situation de deux de tension qui n'est
pas bonne à nos frontières voilà moi je
considérais que l'europe elle pouvait
alors il ya tout le débat sur la partie
de la turquie qui est européenne
istanbul le reste de la turquie moi
j'étais j'assume un partisan de
l'intégration de la turquie dans l'union
européenne je crains malheureusement que
ce ne soit plus possible aujourd'hui
pour des raisons de terrorisme de
radicalisation d'erdogan pour des
raisons politiques globales pour des
raisons de rejet effectivement pour des
raisons de au regard des conflits qui se
sont déroulées aux portes et
de la turquie et qui pèse sur la vie
politique turque pour plein de raisons
mais
alors là on me demande de vous secouer
un peu
vous trouvez qu'on vous a passé ce coup
et qu'on était gentil hein ça va lâcher
et confortable pour l'instant ça va
pourquoi l électrique non le pot
électrique est-ce que vous avez des
rêves un peu oui plein
plein j'ai plein de rêve d'écrire des
romans parce que j'adore écrire des
romans des rêves personnels ou des rêves
me
politiques publiques je vous réfère
outil qui en a ça cela mais non non j'ai
plein de rêves pour mon pays pour des
choses qui me passionnent sur des des
combats que je mène j'ai parlé du made
in france je pourrais vous parler de mes
combats que j'ai pu mener sur le le le
végétal le végétarien sur toutes ces
questions oui j'ai plein de rêves mais
heureusement que j'ai des rêves sinon je
serais je serai je serai je serai frère
un astre mort un astre mort on sait si
on diéma crew non
magron vous avez quel avis sur macro
je vois que vous gratter un peu le nez
quel est mon avis sur mac rang je suis
j'ai son audace m'a fasciné
son audace politique ce
afin d'avoir l'audace pour pour
bousculer une maturité peut-être
moi j'appelle ça de l'audace on appelle
ça comme on veut et une forme de culot
mais qui peut être dû à ce que vous
évoquez mais qui est une forme de culot
mais en tout cas
et au fond je me dis aujourd'hui dans la
classe politique française
il ya quelqu'un qui ferait mieux
j'ai pas je pas sûr
sarkozy ferait mieux ou pas tu pas sûr
pourquoi parce que je pense que on est
dans un monde de zapping et quand on a
été on est plus quand on a quitté la vie
politique on n'y revient pas et que
les temps sont extraordinairement
compliquée ce qui pèse sur les
politiques
et lourd que la défiance est très forte
pour plein de raisons que qu'on a
expliqué comme accro comme un crédit
venu me chercher il se rend pas compte
qu'il est en france oui raconte qui
nourrit il sera encore sur une
provocation se rend pas compte de la pia
pratiquer le régicide il se il se rend
pas compte que la petite phrase
sortie de son contexte peut avoir une
violence inouïe et que toutes les
petites phrases sont des bombes à
fragmentation et qui effectivement quand
on fait de la politique c'est très
compliqué on peut plus rien dire sans
courir le risque que la petite phrase
soit extraite et vous reviennent dans la
figure en boomerang ça a commencé avec
chirac sur le bruit et l'odeur
sauf une bonne chance au mur oui mais je
veux dire que c'était le début mais ça
s'est amplifié avec on va les passer au
karcher avec toutes ces petites phrases
qui sont revenu en boomerang les sondes
ont traversé la rue wee cc voyez je
serai encore la politique je suis pas
sûr que je pourrai entre guillemets me
risquer dans un exercice comme celui
qu'on fait ce soir sans nom sans prendre
le risque de sortir la petite phrase qui
reviennent en boomerang
la cheville jean fesci revient de
petites phrases en boomerang je n'ai
rien à vendre
petit politiquement j'entends un
politique c'est un câble ou c'est ça il
était à un câble ou des trucs à vendre
bien sûr tout avant de coincer non un
politique c'est quelqu'un qui essaye
d'expliquer qu'ils essayent d'expliquer
un monde complexe par des mots simples
et qui est et oui bah oui pour que ça
tienne dans le format
est ce que ce soir on a du temps et
c'est précieux c'est agréable de pouvoir
dérouler j'espère que les gens vont
venir au regard de rendre plus longtemps
possible mais quand vous avez trois
minutes 50 quand vous avez
trail et là bas alors parce que vous
pouvez pas faire autrement c'est quoi
c'est dû tapinage médiatisée c'est ce
que vous pouvez pas faire autrement
parce qu'il ya de la vie démocratique
elle s'incarne par une démocratie
d'opinion etc l'opinion vous pouvez pas
passer à côté en disant je veux pas et
entendre le menu pilloud bas c'est ce
qui est forgée à travers le prisme des
médias des médias des réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs pour moi médias réseaux
sociaux c'est la même chose le prisme ou
des micros des écrans qui qui qui fait
que votre parole va frapper un nombre de
cerveaux conséquent vous pouvez pas
faire autrement nous revenons au made in
france fabriqué en français est ce qu'il
faudrait pas commencer par payer ses
impôts en france
c'est oui c'est mieux quand on paye ses
impôts en france vous payez vos impôts
en france ah oui oui vous allez toujours
pays visant toujours
je me gratte mais ce n'est pas parce que
j'ai c'est acide sais j'ai toujours payé
mes impôts en france jamais payer des
impôts en dehors de france m et j'ai
toujours considéré que je payer beaucoup
d'impôts d'ailleurs quand on paie des
impôts trop toujours qu'on en paye trop
pas mal pas mal
renault médine france vrai ou fait quoi
on fait une petite pétition et 1000
signatures puis on va voir macro et dit
bon écoute macro pas compte des 1000
signatures qui après on va les voir
l'europe ils auront plus à faire c'est
bien yves
non content quand on a regardé un petit
peu ce qui se passait autour d'autres
actualités on s'est dit encore un
politique qui va surfer sur le made in
france pas politique c'est pour ça qu'on
a fait venir
henvic science est une conviction vous
avez fait un rapport en 2010 pour
nicolas sarkozy à propos du made in
france ou du produire en france oui
après c'est encore le sujet cette
nécessité en 2010 saiem rapport payer
avec notre peau young a servi à rien
c'est alors d'abord c'était payé avec
votre pognon sens qu'à l'époque je
vivais sur l'argent public oui sur ce
sujet mais ce rapport on en a extrait
une chose qui est d'avoir créé une
certification sap est la certification
origine france garantie qui est la seule
certification qui permet de garantir
l'origine des produits on s'inspirait
des suisses parce qu'ils sont pas dans
l'europe en créant des critères qui sont
assez exigeants et en créant un procès
sous ses pas l'entreprise qui dit
produit les français c'est un organisme
extérieur qui vient qui fait les
vérifications qui est payée par
l'entreprise comme tous les organismes
de certification mais qui fait un
rapport note pour dire ce produit les
français n'est pas français et cie les
français au titre des critères qu'on a
fixés il ya le tampon le label origine
france garantie ça ça existe c'est 600
entreprises qui s'en sont emparés ces
trois quatre mille gamme de produits et
ça crée de l'emploi ça crée de
l'activité sur ce sujet ça a permis sans
doute d d d usine à vivre des des
consommateurs acheter des produits et de
la transparence donc si je pensais que
tout est vain et que rien ne sert à rien
je serai pas là je serai dans mon jardin
en train de faire pousser mes légumes
sur ces sujets je pense qu'on peut faire
changer les choses je pense que il ya
l'opinion publique qui est importante
qui est un acteur important de la
démocratie d'aujourd'hui elle est assez
ouverte elle est prête sur le made in
france à à s'engager là on vit elle
souhaite l'a compris les enjeux avant
sans doute les politiques et que
maintenant il faut bouger le système
pour que les politiques qui puissent
faire avancer les choses moi je suis
passé du politique élu du politique et
lui ai payé par la nation j'avais le
sentiment de pas faire des choses à
aujourd'hui comment dire le l'homme de
des organisations non gouvernementales
qui veut faire agir les choses de
l'extérieur mais oui je pense qu'on peut
faire bouger les choses alors
effectivement la pétition d'abord elle
est un peu plus de mille signataires à
l'heure on parle puisque quand avant
d'arriver chez vous j'ai regardé on
devait être pas loin de 2700 aux 1800
moi j'espère qu'on sera beaucoup plus
nombreux dernière répétition que j'ai
lancée pour les menus végétariens dans
les écoles on a fini à 285 milles donc
c'est pas si mal que ça et peut-être que
si tous ceux qui suivent
7,7
je sais pas internet oui oui mais c'est
tt review je sais pas comment il faut
dire en tout cas nos échanges sont
motivés se serait pas si con de réserver
le drapeau français aux produits
français et qui vont signer vous avez
des centaines de milliers de personnes
qui vous suivent peut-être ça peut faire
monter et peut-être qu'on peut faire
bouger le système peut-être qu'on peut y
croire peut-être qu'on peut se dire
juste avec un clic on va faire des
choses moi je vais pas renoncer à croire
que c'est possible je m'emmerde pas pour
mon intérêt personnel je m'embête parce
que je pense que c'est possible qu'on
peut y arriver et que quand je vais
visiter l'usiné de haute loire qui
fabrique des bonnets et qui à ce qui
s'appelle les ateliers perrache qui a un
savoir faire incroyable et que je vois
dans le même temps le le quinze de
france fait faire ses bonnets au
portugal ça me fout les boules voilà sur
ce sujet j'ai rien contre le portugal
j'ai rien contre le cof 15 de france
mais jeudi on a des ouvriers on a des
gens qui ont un savoir-faire pourquoi on
les fait pas beau c'est pourquoi on voit
pourquoi on retrouve pas un peu de
simplicité un peu de bon sens pu lui
poser une question ouais dans l'est de
simplicité de bon sens
notre pays notre grand pays la france
non le pays qui est en voie de thiant
moody's suggère mende isation être
contradictoires des gens qu'on a un
grand pays où un grand pays tiers monde
y bientôt c'est ça on a vu une
entreprise de masques oui on la ferme
est en pleine pandémie
on mâche est encore pour 5 milliards de
matériel aux chinois oui et vous savez
quoi laisser quoi c'est quoi c'est de
l'incompétence et c'est quoi c'est un
mix de plein de choses un cocktail de
trek 2 je m'en foutisme sam et
l'incompétence
d'un capitalisme qui dure on s'en fou
autant les seuls fabricants chinois on
va gagner plus en important qu'en
fabriquant nous mêmes il faut aussi
souligner la problématique du monde de
l'entreprise lui même mais qui se
suicident hyper 10 pouces et sa wii
enfin capitalisme échevelé c'est pas que
le libéralisme c'est c'est l'appât du
gain d'ailleurs quand on rapatrie
aujourd'hui de la production de masques
chirurgicaux c'est des machines qu'on
achète hôtes chinois parce qu'on a perdu
le savoir-faire des machines sur ce
sujet pour ça que je vous dis que
produire en france un projet de société
que c'est un projet global que c'est un
projet complexe à un projet d'une
génération
enfermé non pas du tout
d'ailleurs je parle de médine france
souvent de bee ware vaut un briquet en
ferons un audit médine faut dire
fabriquer non je dis je me dis made in
france exprès parce que made in france
vous avez la vision fermée en disant
produit pour nous et on est en autarcie
on a tous fermés et on s'enferme sur
nous-mêmes et moi j'ai une vision
ouverte on est fier de ce qu'ont produit
on le consomme et on le vend et dans un
monde qui s'ouvre et qui a besoin
d'acheter eh bien on fait on fait sauter
les nos produits ce qui est de dire
attendez je termine assez bien parce que
voudriez et comme vous êtes plus tard
pour me perturber je veux oublier
produire en france c'est aussi la
culture
pourquoi est ce que quand vous vendez à
l'étranger un produit français il a il a
quelque chose de plus qu'un produit qui
n'est pas français il a tout l'affect
qui est portée par la france et dense
est affecté à la culture et le
rayonnement culturel de notre pays la
force culturelle de notre pays elle
donne de la puissance à notre industrie
qu'est ce qu'il vous reste culturel dont
les français il nous reste beaucoup de
choses fermé aujourd'hui mais il nous
reste quand même du cinéma du théâtre de
la littérature
il nous reste quand même notre politique
le théâtre politique c'est quoi le tas
politique c'est ce grand barnum qu'on a
tous les jours mon revenu à dakar où il
est et je me disais les politiques vont
reprendre un petit coup je les comprends
coc sur meetic ou non mais je veux dire
que le français sera une des langues les
plus parlées dans le monde à cause de la
natalité africaine avec l'anglais dans
le siècle qui vient c'est un atout
culturel conséquent mais si ça porte pas
notre industrie 6 apporte pas nos usines
6 apporte pas nos ateliers this a fait
le pas du boulot à nos enfants ça sert
juste à une élite moi je veux produire
en france c'est un projet de société
c'est mobilisateur pour toute la société
c'est pas une anecdote c'est pas ringard
c'est pas assez s'est motivé la société
rcc sauver la france sauver son tissu
économique
c'est un show alors il faut dire en
français quoi acheter français parce que
notre état ventripotent n'est pas
capable de protéger les boîtes
françaises donc voté avec votre carte
bleue et protéger des boîtes françaises
où il faut dire à l'état sortez-vous un
peu les lois du faut dire les deux faut
dire les deux il faut regarder dans le
plan de relance le gouvernement il a mis
une petite enveloppe kit enveloppe non
mes petites enveloppes c'est pas
l'expression vous pouvez avoir à
l'esprit l'ami crédit je crois que
quelques centaines de millions pour les
relocalisations pour dire ce qui
ramènerait des usines en france on va
les aider les crédits ont été consommés
pour trois ans tout de suite bon mettons
plus d'argent lançons le grand défi de
dire il faut des rouquins gens parce qu
ils pouvaient voir à grande vitesse
pardon il sort d'où d'argent il sort des
emprunts c'est un mythe oui donc c'est
bien la glisse mais mais j'ai jamais dit
que c'était mal s'endetter ça dépend
pour quoi cissé s'endetter pour créer
des usines qui vont créer de la richesse
c'est plutôt vachement bien la dette sur
ce sujet là je parle beaucoup des
suisses et je vous ai parlé de la
législation suisse et on leur passe le
bonjour et on leur passe le bonjour
parce que nous lisons dans ce monde j'ai
eu un discours avec un ami suisse qui
m'a dit oh boh la suisse et la france on
se ressemble beaucoup c'est quand on
vous sait le canton de vaud 1 en disant
on est très copain on est très semblable
j'imite mal l'accent mais celui que
j'avais il parlait comme ça et il a dit
on à une église dans chaque village
comme vous un mais nous on a une
différence avec vous on a aussi une
usine dans chaque village c'était très
juste et au fond cette france des
territoires mais oui les suisses il perd
l'humour ou plus ils produisent et cette
france des territoires
cette france du rural cette france d
oublier cette france des gilet jaune
elle s'incarne autour des usines et
s'incarne autour des ateliers j'ai été
il ya quelques temps france vinci
j'étais il ya quelques semaines en
tournage d'une émission que je fais pour
public sénat qui fait visiter les usines
et
les gens mais les téléspectateurs
visiter les usines et j'étais dans le
finistère et j'étais dans le taxi entre
entre quimper et pouldreuzic et
pouldreuzic est une entreprise qui
s'appelle l'entreprise hénaff qui est
une entreprise centenaire qui fait du
pathé qui a 300 salariés trapu par l214
qui s'est fait attraper par l214 qui
essaye de faire des progrès des efforts
sur le bien-être animal et dans le taxi
le chauffeur de taxi me dit ah vous
venez faire un reportage sur les 9 juil
j'ai alors vous en pensez quoi me dit
bon heureusement qu'on les uns parce que
les jeunes il aurait travaillé ou mais
tout est dit et cette france du
déséquilibre vers l'urbain cette france
qui a cru que les services allaient tout
feu tout régler cette france qui a cru
que le commerce allait pouvoir vendre
tout sauf des produits français est une
france qui qui qui s'est appauvrie
culturellement économiquement
socialement c'est pour ça que je plaide
pour la florence des usines et des
ateliers pour ça que je pense qu'on peut
y arriver alors évidemment ma petite
affaire sur le drapeau bleu blanc rouge
c'est une petite affaire mais c'est le
déclencheur de quelque chose de plus
important et moi j'y crois je crois
qu'on peut produire en france qu'on peut
être fier des gens qui produisent ce que
j'ai rencontré ce que j'ai filmé ce que
j'ai essayé de mettre en avant sont des
gens formidables ils sont fiers de ce
qu'ils font glee non avec des chefs
d'entreprise des dizaines de noms de
deux des entrepreneurs si j'en cite
certains et pas les autres ils vont
le châtel dans le doubs et que vous
voyez l'entreprise christelle qu'elle
héritière du grand groupe industriel
japy que vous voyez des ouvriers qui
vous explique que 1 qui travaillait chez
peugeot mais qui que pour rien au monde
ils partiraient maintenant que chez
christelle tellement il est fier de ce
qui fait qu'il est fier de vendre des
casseroles qu'ils entrent dans le monde
entier parce que juste elles sont
françaises elles sont belles elles sont
bien faites quand vous allez à
montjean-sur-loire la manufacture 49
voir une entreprise qui était créée il
ya plus d'un siècle par le groupe eram
aujourd'hui qui est un grand groupe
mondial qu'à garder une usine de
production de chaussures et que voyez
des ouvriers qui vous disent mon est
fière de fabriquer des baskets parce que
quand on baisse les yeux au supermarché
qu'on voit des gens qu'on au basket on
est fier de ce qu'on a fait c'est vous
donne quand même une autre idée de ce
que pourrait être la france que ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui et qu'un pays qui ce qui
se regarde le nombril qui est malheureux
et qui n'a plus de fierté la fierté de
produire c'est quelque chose d'important
et ça va de l'agriculteur en circuit
court qui fait du bio dans son dense
dans son potager jusque effectivement
aux ouvriers des plus grandes usines des
marques françaises qui jouent pas le jeu
c'est à dire qu'il dise voilà on est
français mais que derrière
ça produit ailleurs il sait que sa
finance ailleurs alors il ya celle ce
qu'on peut yaël et à celle utilisée est
ce qu'on peut appeler ça des traîtres il
ya celles qui le font parce qu'elles
peuvent pas faire autrement parce que si
elle ne trouve pas un équilibre elles
peuvent plus produire en france et elle
essaye de trouver un équilibre faut le
monde est tel qu'il est je le regrette
mais des tels qu'ils n'aient puis à
celles qui sont les gros filous qui
fabrique ça tout petit peu en france
presque tous à l'extérieur et qui vous
rebâti jaune tout en bleu blanc rouge
c'est ça que je dénonce quand vous voyez
une grande marche contre la fusion va
citer une grande marque française cas
des actionnaires suisses qui
incarne le savoir-faire textile français
qu'à logo qui est un crocodile d'un coup
ça donne pas de noms qui vous vend une
paire de baskets avec le crocodile bleu
blanc rouge dessus bleu blanc rouge et
que quand vous fouillez l'intérieur de
la basket vous découvrez qu'elle est
faite au vietnam ses lilas coust elle
est faite au vietnam moi ça me pose deux
problèmes le premier c'est le mensonge
sur le crocodile bleu blanc rouge il a
le droit d'utiliser le blue wing mais
c'est sûr c'est un mensonge c'est pour
ça que je veux qu'une loi réserve
l'utilisation du drapeau bleu blanc
rouge aux produits français c'est pour
ça que ça me choque et ça me choque il
ya une deuxième chose qui me choque
c'est que si cette basket
avec la gauche ou ce polo mais en
l'occurrence une basket avec a produit
avec un drapeau bleu blanc rouge il
était vendu avec une marge normale
devrait être vendu 40 ou 50 euros parce
qu'effectivement il est produit pour 10
ou 15 euros au vietnam mais il est vendu
140 euros c'est à dire le même prix que
la basket fabriqué à montjean sur loire
en france et ça c'est dégueulasse parce
que le low cost il bénéficie pas aux
consommateurs en l'occurrence bibi il
s'est acquis par dont bénéficierait qui
bénéficie aux importateurs à la marque
au système sur sa dividende oui sans
doute mais bon c'est un libéral je
comprends le système mais le système
s'équilibre par quoi le système
capitaliste qui s'équilibre par la
responsabilité de l'acheteur par la
transparence de l'acheteur dans le
sillage des passants découvrent en
général oui dans l'histoire mais moi je
rêve qui s'équilibre par par une société
plus responsable et si je reste sur
l'exemple de ma basket avec mon
crocodile bleu blanc rouge s'il l'était
dit que les fabricants au vietnam de
façon très lisible et qui est pas de
crocodile bleu blanc rouge peut-être que
le consommateur il dirait une basket
faite au vietnam moi je veux pas la
payer plus de 50 euros voilà mais on a
la même chose avec le maillot de
l'équipe de france de football avec les
deux étoiles fabriqué en thaïlande pour
5 euros vendu 80 euros what the fuck
c'est quoi ce scandale c'est quoi ce
scandale et la fédération française
couvre son équipementier qui couvre tout
le monde alors qu'on pourrait faire et
moi je connais des dizaines
d'entreprises qui peuvent fabriquer le
maillot de l'équipe de france pour un
prix raisonnable c'est
dans le nord chez lemahieu à côté de
lille dans plein d'endroits en france
qui peut fabriquer rudi 1 orion le même
maillot de l'équipe de france qui peut
être vendu 80 euros avec une bonne
marche pour tout le monde c'est quoi une
bonne marge c'est ça dépend du type de
produit c'est un ennemi à 2-2 et demi
mes parents étaient commerçants et à
l'époque merci il en est des vêtements à
besançon et à l'époque ce beau jour un
franche-comte lobbies ou pas aux
byzantins gens de beuzec et il va pontus
aussi au passage oui c'est un message
chacun bois l'apéritif qui le souhaitent
et invite à billes oui et bien sûr et
et aux amis de la cancoillotte qui va
devenir iger p je vais faire du du
mont-dore et du mont-dore et et du
vacherin alors en l'occurrence et du
comté et du pulsar d'arbois problème
avec l'écologie le couper en ce moment
là bas on a un problème si c'est les
vaches bête non il paraît que le
raconter le conte est en train de
ravager toutes les rivières alors je ne
sais pas mais est-ce qu'on va pas avoir
un problème c'est à dire que si on
réalise tri la france comme en chine on
va se retrouver à massacrer comme en
chine non parce que on ad on a justement
une réglementation qui est exigeante
qu'on peut rendre encore plus exigeants
c'est ce qui plombe de notre
compétitivité les coûts de production
mais c'est parce que on a un niveau
social un niveau sanitaire un niveau
environnemental qui est exigeant et
qu'au contraire quand on produit en
france
on pollue moins que quand on produit en
chine et ont fait pas travailler des
enfants ce qui est quand même une vraie
différence sur ce sursaut politique juin
pourquoi on fêtera idées et ses mots
mais pas des mineurs
et des mineurs
revenus revenons à la pollution
importé manon est ce que est ce que vous
y croyez vraiment c'est la créa d'istres
réindustrialisation de la france alors
que la majeure partie des français tout
loto de milo que la chine a
subordonné soudoyer un toxique qui
appelez ça comme vous voulez les
consommateurs avec des produits de merde
à la chine qui a fait ça c'est les
politiques ont laissé la chine venir
chez nous c'est ça
par nature
j'ai compris que les politiques sont
responsables de tout compose salah les
politiques sont responsables de tous les
désordres du monde ils sont coupables
une fois qu'on a posés là on va
s'envoler sur tes analyses qu'on va
partager ensemble sur des choses un peu
différentes
sur ce la france qui
vous je vous dis c'est pas la chine qui
a fait ça c'est la grande distribution
qui a été chercher des marges plus
importantes et qui a été chercher des
pays low cost pour fabriquer à moindre
coût et pour continuer à vendre à court
moyen et a gagné beaucoup d'argent en
jeu encore une fois je suis un libéral
je constate et je ne reproche pas je dis
simplement qu'il ya eu une défaillance
dans l'est dans l'équilibrage et que la
fiscalité peut rééquilibrer sa pourquoi
je propose à tva kilométrique c'est quoi
mon idée de tva kilométrique c'est
l'idée suivante c'est de dire on
pourrait avoir un taux de tva qui soit
avec un souk lahad ouzou 15 et contre 12
et 15 ou 15 et 25 ça varie en fonction
du nombre de kilomètres café le produit
pour venir entre les endroits et les
fabriquer est l'endroit où il est vendu
c'est très juste c'est très écolo parce
que ça fait vraiment circuits courts si
vous produisez à proximité vous payez
moins que si vous produisez loin nos
voisins qui produisent le maghreb la
turquie qui nous vendent des produits
seraient moins frappés que l'asie qui
sont beaucoup plus éloignés beaucoup
moins respectueux d'un certain nombre de
règles et c'est simple à mettre en
oeuvre
et là on aurait un levier compréhensible
par le citoyen est un levier qui
pourrait permettre de rééquilibrer un
peu les choses d'ailleurs les politiques
comme vous dites tourne autour depuis
des années c'est ce qu'on appelle la
taxe carbone aux frontières parce qu' on
cherche le graal de ce sujet mais le
graal c'est la tva kilométrique et et
quand on dit non mais c'est difficile ce
pas difficile du tout tout celui qui
vend dans un supermarché ou sur une
plateforme internet il sait de quelle
usine se sont produits ici on sait
calculer le nombre de kilomètres café le
produit c'est pas difficile à calculer
sur question d'internet c'est quoi la
marque de votre montre la masse et une
swatch
france annonce une swatch ou médine
suisse
vous me dites pas suisse en l'occurrence
je crois qu'elle est faite en suisse
parce que c'est le modèle un peu cher
non je crois pas que ce soit le modèle
cher avec la modèle à 114 euros pourquoi
pourquoi vous n'avez pas l'ips où il de
penser elle alors j'ai une collection de
livres parce que comme je viens de
besançon j'ai une collection de l'ip
j'ai une chance de gould a préféré g
monde une montre routine parce que je
jette beaucoup florian chausson qui est
un jeune très courageux qui est en train
de recréer une filière horlogère
française 100% française et qui a créé
une marque qui s'appelle routine sur ce
sujet me change de monde ce matin je me
la swatch voilà ça dépend de mon humeur
je n'ai pas j'ai pas fait un choix en me
disant oh là là je vais aller chez des
gens qui vous regardé ma montre donc
j'ai mis ma swatch il veut de petit
prince libre look scooby doo c'est que
ça c'est ce qu'on donne à l'association
origine france garantie
voilà bleu blanc rouge un petit à petit
un petit un petit bracelet pour montrer
qu'on est attaché au made in france il
est franc en france du géant français
c'est difficile de s'habiller de
s'équiper en vue france oui c'est enfin
c'est dire oui c'est qu'est ce que vous
pensez de montebourg mais j'ai beaucoup
arnaud
on se connaît on sait on a eu deux vies
politiques un peu parallèle quand il
était ministre nommé par
françois hollande j'ai été le voir je
lui dis tu sais j'ai créé la
certification origine france garantie sa
démarche puisqu'on l'avait créée l'année
d'avant bon voila si tu penses que je ne
suis pas apte à la préside et parce que
j'étais un je suis un homme de droite
moi je suis prêt à laisser les clés
parce que je pense que c'est plus
important que ma personne dit mais non
je le trouve c'est super on va
travailler ensemble et puis quand ils
allaient sortie du gouvernement eh bien
on a on a mené plein de combat
médiatique ensemble pour le made in
france dans un attelage on a fait le en
même temps avant l'heure il y avait en
même temps un homme de droite est un
homme de gauche sur ce sujet aujourd'hui
il est au conseil d'administration de
l'association origine france garantie
puisque le miel bleu-blanc ruchette
origine france garantie et
voilà je l'apprécient beaucoup je
partage pas tout sa vision politique
mais c'est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
qui est un homme de sincérité que
montebourg versus macro voté quoi
ça c'est un piège je ne répondrai pas à
cette question
sur ce sur ce sujet je sais pas je ne
sais pas il faut voir les programmes les
alliances
je fuis pas la question mais ses
conseillers de faire le stum qu'est ce
que je pense de l'affairé alsthom c'est
que ça fait partie sans doute des sujets
dont on dira dans le futur que c'était
que ça a été des grands scandales
industriels
on a laissé faire
ça fait mal non oui surtout en plus
alstom general electric il y en a dans
votre région ou non oui oui là partout
bien sûr sur ces postes bonjour oui
c'est à facettes
ça fait mal
c'est là où ou quand les politiques
coupables de tous
parlent d' état stratège il faut que ça
s'incarne par des réalités il faut pas
que ce soit des mots faut que ce soit
des réalités et que moi je pense que
l'état a un rôle sur ces sujets-là
d'être stratège et d'éviter que
les entreprises industrielles françaises
ne deviennent les proies d'enjeux qui
sont pas des enjeux d'intérêt national
qui sont des enjeux capitalistique alors
ils existent et ils sont ils sont pas
illégitimes simplement l'état doit
réguler vous m'avez posé la question
tout à l'heure sur la régulation
et en disant le libéralisme c'est
l'absence de régulation non le
libéralisme et la liberté d'entreprendre
mais avec une régulation qui fait que
les intérêts premier des pays des états
des nations sont défendus du peuple donc
des peuples naturellement edf gdf ça
vous fait penser à court en ce moment
edf gdf ça me fait penser à
d'abord un petit privé de ses six
manches non je pense c'est plus
compliqué que ça je pense que c'est un
un montage
qui
n'est pas très libéral et que au
contraire derrière tout ça il ya le
maintien de la toute puissance de l'état
dans la grande maison edf qui est quand
même confronté à la concurrence sur la
question de la production d'énergie
parce que il ya deux choses dedans et
des filles à la production d'énergie
avec le nucléaire qui est un un vrai
sujet en soi un sujet stratégique un
sujet de savoir faire un sujet de
compétences locales ce tome où l'asnl au
sein
si si on veut aussi si on continue à
dépecer le savoir-faire d'alstom et au
profit des américains oui on l'a dans
l'os sur ce sujet et puis il ya gdf la
production donc essentiellement le
nucléaire mais pas seulement puis à la
distribution il ya le réseau que ce soit
le réseau de distribution où que ce soit
le réseau de transport d'électricité et
là je pense que derrière ce qu'on
appelle hercule le projet recul ça c'est
pas la privatisation c'est au contraire
le maintien d'une toute puissance qui
n'est pas forcément très saine et moi je
pense que la distribution est là il faut
que j'arrête de me frotter les mains je
pense que la distribution et le
transport de l'électricité
devrait sortir du giron d'une entreprise
qui évoque dans le secteur concurrentiel
et devrait être totalement totalement
rendus publics parce que les réseaux de
transport c'est fondamental sur
l'électricité si le réseau de transport
est pas tenue et le réseau de
distribution est pas tenue
c'est pas le plus compliqué en matière
d'énergie et production d'électricité
s'est pas de produire de l'énergie c'est
de la transporter de la distribuer et là
il ya un vrai sujet est au fond je pense
qu'on est à contre vérité quand on dit
c'est une privatisation rampante non je
pense qu'au contraire c'est une volonté
d'aider f de garder la main sur tout
mais ça ça me semble pas très sain
est-ce que vous pensez que nos services
de renseignement protège correctement
nos boîtes ce que le renseignement
économique français ne s'est pas un peu
relâché
infiltrés ou
détendu est-ce qu'on est un petit peu en
short en termes de renseignements
économiques d'intelligence économique
est ce que l'intelligence économique
seppois l'économie de l'intelligence
maintenant en france si sans doute scène
c'est une belle pirouette sémantique
mais
je pense d'abord que nos services de
renseignement se sont beaucoup consacré
sur le terrorisme pour des raisons
douloureuse qu'on comprend tout ce que
les moyens étant pas fini ce qu'on a
concentré sur le terrorisme religieux
n'était pas sur d'autres sujets que la
question d'intelligence économique et de
la protection
est majeure et qu'elle peut louvre la
question de la souveraineté numérique et
que la l'europe a été défaillante et
plus que défaillante par ce par manque
de vision way home est donc deux visions
oui par manque de vision c'est vraiment
bien vu être lobby a pas eu de jeu des
choses pas par manque de vision
tellement de protection de protection
manque de vision par manque de volonté
politique de dire on va mettre de
l'argent pour créer des géants numérique
européen pour nous protéger et
aujourd'hui par manque de volonté de
protéger les seuls qui restent
les ovh les alstom
les palets alstom les atos avec les
super calculateurs qui restent des
outils de 2,1 technip qui restent des
outils de notre souveraineté
numérique moi je pense que si je crois
en l'europe et si je voudrais que
l'europe repartent d'un bon pied c'est
justement pour avoir l'europe des
souverainetés la souveraineté
alimentaire la souveraineté sur les
médicaments génériques la souveraineté
numérique c'est pas les chants d'un pays
on est trop petit pour construire c'est
ce qu'on vend très sale échelons d'une
union qu'il faut construire ces
souveraineté et là on s'est dit on sait
laisser dépouiller par les géants du
monde qui avait des marchés intérieurs
qui portait leur développement c'est le
cas par exemple sur pour prendre un
autre sujet sur la batterie les chinois
et les coréens sont les champions du
monde des batteries parce qu'ils ont
développé un marché intérieur notamment
de véhicules électriques qui leur a
permis de se développer chez eux après
d'exporter dans le monde entier on n'a
pas su faire ça en europe et là l'europe
de de l'industrie de la vision
industrielle elle et elle est à
construire et sur l'intelligence
économique
on revient au sujet de base je pense que
là on a une une vraie une vraie
faiblesse et une vraie faiblesse qui
s'incarne par
le diable le diable numérique qu'on ne
maîtrise plus et qui paraît et toutes
nos données partant d'heure de chez nous
quand je vois tous les gens qui sont sur
les adresses gmail et autres c'est du
gouvernement y compris le gouvernement
on a une petite pensée pour quelqu'un
qui nous étaient chers
robert guillaume ou
à propos de l'intelligence économique
quand vous voyez la ville de vendôme qui
vend son nom à lvmh contre des emplois
ça vous fait penser à quoi
va rien c'est bien il devrait donc ils
vont de leur nom
c'est quoi paris a vendu son nom depuis
longtemps
je crois que les marques territoriales
elles existent que vous trouvez donc
nous nous milliards dire patriotes nos
milliardaires patriotes ceux qui payent
des impôts oui
ceux qui font de l'évasion fiscale non
pour ça qu'ils sont meilleurs des renom
parce qu'ils font d'évasion fiscale ou
parce qu'ils payent des impôts
en tout cas pour répondre à votre
question je pense que les milliardaires
qui payent des impôts en france sont
patriotes
est ce que vous voulez qu'on aborde un
sujet encore
non vous en avez marre déjà deux mois je
vais l'aider si j'en ai marre je finirai
avant 8h30 il reste un quart d'heure
donc
ou alors je vais enfin on apprend 3,4
question internet
mais mais moi je pense du cic ou
le fameux cice cette belle arnaque à 40
milliards r ces gens pensent que c'est
n'est plus un sujet c'est quoi c'est une
arnaque c'est ici du coup c'est d'argent
pour les copains c'est une façon de
virer la caissière pour la remplacer par
des étais une façon socialistes de ne
pas baisser les impôts
ou pas augmenter les impôts
voilà je pense la question de la
fiscalité
elle est globale que notre système
fiscal il est incompréhensible je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure illisible d'une
complexité absolue qu'il ait inventé
d'ailleurs par des gens qui après
passent la moitié de leur vie inventé le
système fiscal le plus compliqué au
monde et l'autre moitié de leur vie à
aider les gens à s'en dédouaner et quand
même un écho si c'est un beau petit
écosystème sa vie sur lui même sur ce
sujet et je pense que une des vraies
réformes de notre pays serait une
réforme de simplification fiscale
alors évidemment
politiquement c'est très compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre en temps normaux parce
que les ceux qui sont gagnants du
nouveau système fiscal viennent jamais
vous dire merci et ceux qui sont
perdants parce qu'ils payent plus haut
tombe tous sur la glace c'est pas vrai
meijaard y regarder lisf
bien des gens qu'on remercie pour l'usf
nom qu'on finance et des campagnes
choses comme ça donc mais quand je parle
de l'opinion publique ne parle pas de
cet aspect là quand il ya eu des
changements par exemple quand on a
changé la taxe professionnelle ait eu
des gagnants et des perdants ce qu'ils
avaient gagné au jeu qui paient moins on
les a pas entendus dans la rue dire
merci au gouvernement et ceux qui paient
plus qui étaient beaucoup moins nombreux
ils ont tous se fait des manifs donc
effectivement c'est ça qui rend la
réforme compliquée et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure où il faudra
ou un événement ou un homme qui ait le
courage de dire on fait des trucs voilà
c'est comme ça et pas s'aimer mais c'est
pas gagné donc je pense que
malheureusement il faudra un événement
pour essayer de reconstruire un nouveau
modèle plus simple plus efficace et que
la question fiscale dès que vous en
prenez un petit bout c'est comme le
mikado un fiscalité et comme le mikado
vous prenez un bout et beaucoup de mal
de dents extraire un bout sans faire
s'effondrer tout le reste qui sont
internet un mot sur la décroissance la
sobriété heureuse
oui moi je suis plus sur une croissance
heureuse qu'une décroissance
adhésion c'est pas la même chose
récession est la décroissance
la récession
la décroissance il ya une notion de
volonté la récession vous la subissez
plus que vous ne vous l'a souhaité moi
je suis pour ces notions alors après il
faut savoir ce qu'on met traitent chacun
derrière tout ça on peut avoir des longs
débats mais moi je pense que liszt
l'idée d'une croissance
durable d'une croissance verte d'une
croissance qui préserve nos ressources
sont certes mais c'est encore c'est du
bullshit washing là c'est pas du
bullshit doit signer c'est à dire de la
croissance c'est quoi
définition la croissance et la
croissance étant de calories par an pour
avoir nos ressources c'est-à-dire on
puisse des calories c'est ça la
croissance non sipa on peut avoir des
définitions différentes la croissance
c'est vous m la définition du bhoutan
c'est ça
pourquoi du beau temps parce qu il est
le produit du beau deux roues énormes et
le si la planète va à 10 milliards il
faudra nourrir cette planète l'équipe et
l'habiller elle a soigné donc faudra de
la croissance vont faire des instincts g
ou ce but mais il faudra de la
croissance oui ou non si on va 10
milliards ça dépend il
faut il faudra cocon nous risquons
habits qu'on répartisse les choses
différemment à guérir si sûr sur ce
sujet là et les peuples aspirons à ce
qu'on peut appeler le progrès qui ne
l'est pas forcément on peut avoir ce
débat philosophique sur ce sujet infinie
mais il aspire rond à ça donc je pense
que tant qu'on aura la bombe
démographique qui nous qui guidera
l'époque et et il faudra qu'on ait de la
croissance pour accompagner cette bombe
démographique et cette croissance il
faut qu'elles soient respectueuses de
nos ressources naturelles sacré défi
qu'elles soient respectueuses de notre
santé c'est la question de la pollution
qui est aussi un sacré défi sur ce sujet
et puis quelle soit au passage aussi
respectueuse de limiter les gaz à effet
de serre parce que c'est vrai choc -
climatique qui est un défi encore plus
dangereux
accord au réchauffement climatique non
pas aux noces capacité à la qualité à
notre capacité à enrayer le
réchauffement climatique et nourrir tout
avant plus de décence de dignité pour
les plus faibles si j'y crois que ça si
j'y crois pas je m'enferme dans un
pessimisme qui va me détruire non et ja
pas de prendre la bonne direction pour
préserver vos compatriotes qu'il n'y a
pas de vous êtes capable de prendre les
bonnes directions pour préserver vos
compatriotes oui moi je suis crois je
pense qu'on peut qu'on peut essayer de
composer sans sortir je suis je reste
optimiste je crois qu'on peut essayer de
concilier des choses qui peuvent
apparaître comme inconciliables que
c'est compliqué que s'est mondialisée
que c'est entre des mains de gens qui de
toute façon on peu de temps pour agir ce
qu'au fond quand vous avez un mandat
électif vous avez vous été lui le temps
que vous soyez élu que vous preniez la
main sur les choses et vous ayez vous
êtes déjà plus au pouvoir donc il ya
aussi la dimension du ray kiki qui joue
et c'est la contrepartie de la
démocratie oui je pense qu'on peut on
peut s'en sortir oui je je parie sur
notre capacité parce qu'il ya quand même
des choses intéressantes qui arrivent
dans notre époque
les disruption technologiques qui font
que ici dans un appartement à paris on
peut toucher 100 mille deux cent mille
je ne sais pas combien de personnes pour
s'exprimer c'est ouais série d'îles
france non mais c'est artisanal mais
yahia k ya quarante ans ça n'aurait pas
existé c'était impossible
et c'était impossible pour moi il ya 40
ans qui commençait la vie politique de
pouvoir me dire qu'un moment j'aurais
l'occasion de pouvoir m'exprimer d'être
entendu par des dizaines de milliers de
personnes de façon simple et pragmatique
je n'avais pas cet outil et si j'avais
voulu distribuer 100 mille tracts
j'aurais fait comment donc c'est aussi
des points la rupture la disruption
technologique elle elle n'est pas que
porteuse de négatifs et les porteuses
aussi de beaucoup de choses positif y
compris pour aller dans les objectifs
qu'on évoquait d'une croissance durable
question internet peut-on
raisonnablement penser rattraper notre
retard sur les gars fin pour assurer
notre souveraineté numérique et bien
c'est ainsi c'est une vraie question
chez eux pour l'instant on voit que même
aux états unis il ya des tentatives de
couper les gaffes parce que en morceaux
j'entends parce que parce que ce sont
des des monstres qui est qui ont qui ont
grandi comme le le le blob c'est le blog
oui c'est une espèce de chose dont on
sait pas ce qu'elle est qui grandit
comme ça tout seul et que personne ne
peut arrêter
il faut il faut se dire que les gaffes à
seront peut-être à leur tour victimes
aussi de rupture qui n'auront pas vu
venir et qui peut céder monstrueux aux
pieds d'argile c'est aussi des monstres
fragile parce que leur modèle repose sur
des technologies qui peuvent être mises
en cause qui peuvent être battues en
brèche et qu'il faut que les états là
interviennent
mon ami bruno lemaire porte cette idée
d'une fiscalité la france d'apporter un
peu tout seul a beaucoup de mal à faire
un peu bouger l'europe mais je pense
qu'il ya une vraie question oui face à
ces géants mondiaux et et on parle des
gaffes mais on pourrait parler aussi des
alors je n'ai plus l'acronyme des géants
chinois et autres vous avez vu
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement chinois
il fait de la régulation quand le patron
d'alibaba sortie de lait pur du discours
officiel on l'a convoqué gentiment pour
lui expliquer qu'il fallait qu'ils se
remettent dans la ligne c'est une
société assez réguler
on voit mal mâcon faire ça sans lui rien
en vous disant que le régime chinois
n'est pas vraiment le modèle de la
démocratie française quand on voit les
gilet jaune quand même on se dit c'est
quoi ça cause de la couleur ou la
essayer de faire des blagues attention
on n'est pas sur bfm on n'enterre pas
des pokémon siens oui c'est vrai que le
pauvre ce pauvre le bout qui le
chevreuil journaliste qui a dit ça alors
question internet qu'il est en très
bonne question que pense-t-il du rôle de
mckinsey et d'accenture dont le
fonctionnement de l'état c'est très
inquiétant c'est très inquiétant parce
que son copain ouais c'est très
inquiétant parce qu'on a une magnifique
formation de nos fonctionnaires
et lena est une école qui forme des très
beaux esprits moi je suis pas sur ceux
qui crachent sur l'ena je suis seul sur
ce qu'ils reprochent que les la soie
salles-la-source la seule source de
formation des élites je pense que
l'élitisme ne peut pas venir que d'un
logiciel unique mais le logiciel énarque
il n'est pas mauvais simplement si c'est
toujours le même logiciel qui décide de
tout ça fonctionne pas et je trouve très
inquiétant qu effectivement sur des
questions notamment d'organisation de
logistique
alors qu'on a une armée qui en matière
de logistique n'est pas la plus mauvaise
au monde loin de là on sait on sait
avoir des opérations extérieures qu'on a
tu te projeter un hôpital de plus de 30
pains sur un parking en est on est quand
même foutu de monter des opérations
extérieures que peu de pays peuvent
remonter enfin les disques elle vous
parlez desquels barkia l'espace au mali
et dans un autre pays on dépend
évidemment largement d africa mais pas
ça s'appelle pas de la logistique ça
s'appelle essayer de survivre avec des
bouts de ficelle bon c'est un peu
caricatural là aussi je termine sur mac
intel est en opex
louis enfin j'ai été j'ai été faire un
séjour sur le charles de gaulle qui
était un no 15 questions très
intéressantes quand on voit notre
industrie de l'armement par exemple les
salissures mckinsey les excuses je pense
que c'est inquiétant et je pense qu'au
fond qu'on se dise qu'on a besoin de
payer des sachants
alors qu'on est censé avoir quand même
une technostructure de haut niveau c'est
un peu inquiétant
c'est magnifique non mais si on n'avait
pas de techno structure de haut niveau
qu'on se dise on est vraiment libéral et
quand on a un problème on fait appel à
omeyer sachant ça ne me choquerait pas
ce qui me choque c'est l'accumulation
des deux des meilleurs sachant franco
français bien entendu enfin bon ok c'est
toutes ces sociétés là ce sont vous vous
connaissez des grandes sociétés
françaises de conseil
qui ont leur le niveau d expertise de l
aspire tout tout tout tout les jeunes
vont travailler chez séché chez ces
géants là malheureusement là aussi un
peu comme nous chercheurs avec les
vaccins c'est un peu ça c'est un
scandale non oui oui de ce masters oui
vachon est un scandale sur les vaccins
c'est sans doute que on se soient
tournés vers les deux grands sanofi
pasteur en disant qu est ce que vous
pouvez faire et que n'oubliez qui avait
toute une série de jeux start peur de la
biotech qui pouvaient répondre d'un rien
le gouvernement anglais ci s'est pas
trompé et on s'est fait piquer comme ça
à savoir faire qui était très français
c'était quoi la question que je vous ai
notre industrie d'armement oui quand on
voit que nos bals de famas maintenant ce
sont des balles autant
c'est normal c'est pas normal
notre industrie c'est à tient ses salons
serre c'est l'industrie de des balles
s'était pas t'y fais pas en fabriquer
les balles moi je suis pour que toutes
précisions je suis je suis d'abord on a
une industrie de l'armement qui est qui
qui étaient importantes et je suis pour
que on est une souveraineté forte
nationale sur ces sujets là et qu'on
soit très attentifs à ces questions là
puisque derrière l'industrie de
l'armement avec tout le débat
philosophique qui peut y avoir il ya
aussi le développement industriel il
découle du savoir faire et des
techniques de l'industrie d'armement de
l'industrie civile extrêmement
intéressante en matière d'innovation en
matière de savoir faire industriel là là
là on est on est on se met en danger sur
ces questions n'est pas ce ratage
le paradoxe français de vouloir apporter
la démocratie non et pour les petites
filles à l'étranger et à côté devant des
missiles
quel paradoxe de tout les pays qui se
croient des grandes démocraties et qui
veulent aspirer le monde de leurs
modèles c'est le paradoxe américain
c'est le paradoxe ils se croient s'est
fait à dessein c'est pourquoi oui parce
que il ya cette espèce d'idée que
regarder notre relation avec l'afrique
on a voulu imposer avec l'aide des au
moment de la décolonisation où on a
voulu imposer ou même on a formé les
élites qui ont essayé de reproduire le
modèle démocratique étatique français
l'ont fait non
le marché non ça n'a pas bien marché il
ya corruption oui je n'ai parallèle je
parlais pas aspect là je parlais du
fonctionnement des états de des systèmes
politiques je pense que on n'a pas assez
respecter la réalité sociologique et et
la réalité historique et la réalité
politique d'un certain nombre de pays et
que quand on veut plaquer un modèle qui
est un modèle qui est le nôtre sur un
certain nombre de nations de pays bas on
court le risque de tomber à côté de la
plaque et que le résultat soit pire que
de n'avoir rien fait
le pantouflage on supprime on en fait
quoi c'est quoi le pantouflage s'est
imaginé vous avez féline a
payé par les impôts français vous avez
été
formé par l'argent français vous occupez
un poste dans un ministère dans une inde
où j'allais dire une industrie française
mais est ensuite vous allez dans le
privé avec votre carnet d'adressés du
public et ensuite je savais qu'elle
était là dennis définition je voulais
vous l'entendre dire si on se voulait
qu'on joue à ce jeu là non pas du tout
mais pour mon équipe a une âme et je
voulais qu'on soit bien d'accord sur la
définition de pantouflage et moi je
considère que
ça fait partie des choses qu'il faut
régler en interdisant enfin en demandant
à celui qui a quitté la fonction
publique de la quitter définitivement et
il ya eu trop de pantouflage vers la
politique il ya eu trop d'élus qui au
fond comme il avait une carrière de
fonctionnaire la protection de leur
carrière de fonctionnaire se disait si
je perds mon mandat il se passe rien
voilà moi je fais partie de ceux qui
quand j'ai quitté la vie politique
volontairement fallu que je retrouve une
activité il n'y avait rien qui
m'attendait il y avait rien de précis
sur cette affaire et je pense qu'il faut
deux pour une société de responsabilité
il faut que celui et il faut pas avoir
parachute devant parachute derrière
parachutes dorés et quand on prend des
risques quand on veut passer de métier
de fonctionnaire au métier de dirigeant
d'entreprise ou quitte la fonction
publique et on y revient pas comme je
suis partisan d'une chose qu'avait
promis d'ailleurs le président de la
république et qui n'est pas fait c'est
ce qu'on appelle le spoil system à la
française je suis partisan que quand un
gouvernement arrive les 200 ou 300
propose deux plus hauts fonctionnaires
il y les nomme
avec une nomination politique aimé que
quand le gouvernement s'en va c'est les
post's hôtels suivants puisse nommer les
hauts fonctionnaires ça limiterait les
cabinets ministériels ça limiterait les
doublons et ça limiterait ce que j'ai pu
connaître à l'époque où j'étais ministre
c'est-à-dire des fonctionnaires qui me
disait cause toujours tu seras partie
avant nous et qui se réjouissent et vous
vous faites au moment où je partais
parce que ça leur permettait d'avoir des
promotions
question internet c'est quoi tes trois
plus grosses erreurs moi
de n'avoir pas mesuré dans la crise à
laquelle j'étais confronté comme
ministre des antilles qui était une
crise très lourde passer le bonjour elie
domota je veux passer le bonjour à tous
les guadeloupéens et en particulier à
elie domota c'est ici si nous écoute
mais à tous les guadeloupéens les
antilles et plus largement parce que ça
marche beaucoup enrichi cette crise nous
a fait du bien plus dans l'île de beauté
en fins non non c'était oui mais au delà
de ça c'est j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses et j'ai appris sur moi-même j'ai
appris politiquement mais ma première
erreur c'est de ne pas d'avoir cru que
bien faire suffisait qu'il fallait pas
ce blindé politiquement par derrière
pour pas sauter et donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai été la victime expiatoire de
cette affaire là ma deuxième
erreur
c'est difficile de dire ses erreurs
politiques c'est sans doute de n'avoir
jamais construit un plan de carrière
puis peut-être mort est emmené un peu
plus loin mais je le regrette pas moi je
j'agis plutôt à l'instinct j'agis au au
feeling j'agis voyez j'accepte des
invitations comme celle de ce soir sans
savoir où je venais ce que je venais
faire prendre une soupe mais si c'est
vrai mais je vous promets sans connaître
le modèle et j'ai vu une interview de
montebourg non j'avais vu les dix
premiers minutes de l'interview de
montebourg sur ce sujet je regrette rien
voilà je fais les choses comme je les ai
je les ressens donc je suis plus
instinctif et puis ma dernière erreur ça
a été sans doute
d'essayer de régler le problème
politique de ma succession dans la ville
de montereau et de me représenter aux
élections à la demande de tout de tout
ce qui
étaient mes amis politiques qui
trouvaient que la situation n'allait pas
bien alors que j'avais quitté la vie
politique et ça a été très mal compris
donc ce n'était pas une erreur
d'affection c'est pas une erreur sur le
fond mais c'est une erreur parce qu'ils
étaient mal comprise des habitants c'est
aujourd'hui et sans doute plein d'autres
mais je n'ai pas réfléchi à mes erreurs
on va parler une question interne qui
mal formulé je vais essayer de la
reformuler
l'immigration les réfugiés
l'immigrant tous eu
cette incompréhension même en termes
évoqués blair
c'est étrange parce que quand vous quand
vous quittez votre pays pour aller
travailler vous êtes un expatrié
et quand vous quittez votre pays pour
aller travailler mais venant d'un
certain nombre d'autres pays vous
devenez ami grand ce qui est quand même
un vocabulaire très étrange moi je suis
j'ai toujours été les hôtes ou début de
ma vie politique j'avais beaucoup
d'admiration pour bernard stasi qu'avait
créé un livre qui s'appelait
l'immigration une chance pour la france
et qui était très d'étonnant dans ma
famille politique sur ce sujet et j'ai
été maire d'une ville frappée par la
question migratoire je pense que à force
de ne pas régler ce problème on en fait
une bombe à retardement et à force de ne
pas mettre en place des règles claires
et lisibles de de migration et les
règles claires et lisibles sont fondés à
mon avis sur le travail je pense que le
la régularisation ou l'acceptation dans
notre pays de migrants elle est fondée
sur quelqu'un qui a un travail quelqu'un
qui trouve un travail quelqu'un qui est
en activité
doit pouvoir être accepté aux
régularisés et avant de partir j'avais
déposé 1 2 dernière proposition de loi à
l'assemblée qui est dans le grand
cimetière des propositions de loi pour
qu'on essaie de s'inspirer du modèle ken
canadien sur l'immigration qui est un
modèle intéressant sur le parrainage et
je pense qu'on serait qu'on irait
beaucoup mieux en matière migratoire si
on met en place un système de parrainage
si on demandait aux français de devenir
citoyen responsable et d'accepter de
parrainer des migrants
et alors les canadiens ont une expertise
ses montées c'est réguler s'est
organisée mais je pense que il faut
mettre un peu d'humanisme dans tout ça
est que les images qu'on voit de
lampedusa des morts dans la méditerranée
des sons des images qui ne crée que que
la douleur est que la tension y compris
politiques et qu'il faut qu'on ait une
vraie politique migratoire beaucoup plus
lisible et fondé sur le parrainage si
vous acceptez si vous voulez parrainer
un migrant voulait dès que vous
l'accompagnez que vous signez un contrat
avec lui et bien aller allons-y avançons
parce que le paradoxe c'est que c'est
compliqué de signer un contrat avec
quelqu'un comme ça pourquoi mais gêné
vous si les canadiens y arrive wen mais
je vais vous dire les saoudiens font peu
près la même chose il signe un contrat
pro ne passe pas en paix tranquille
on n'est pas toujours obligé de voir ce
qui marche pas on peut voir aussi ce qui
peut fonctionner sur ce modèle est sûre
sur les migrations sur le le le cette
question là je pense qu'il faut être
clair qu'il faut pas qu'on que des gens
restent en france par défaut parce que
le système ils sont tombés à côté du
système et sur cette affaire qu'il faut
fixer des règles qu'il faut accompagner
j'ai été membre du haut conseil à
l'intégration je pense que la question
de l'intégration et les majeures parce
qu'à force de ne pas traiter
l'immigration et de laisser faire sans
règles précises dont on rate les
intégrations aussi et qu'il faut qu'on
revisite sa non pas dans une vision
négative est fermée dans une vision
positive de dire dans quelles conditions
on peut accueillir des migrants et on en
aura besoin si on produit en france si
on va vers la société à laquelle
j'aspire du made in france on aura
besoin d'eux de manoeuvre est peut-être
que la france ne suffira pas sur cette
main d'oeuvre qu'il faut effectivement
lié au développement économique cette
question migratoire ou essai c'est un
vrai sujet extrêmement douloureux
douloureux dans tous les sens du titien
pas bête du tout quand tout
quand on gagne le rsa comment on se paye
du made in france compliqué extrêmement
compliqué mais quand on gagne le rsa et
qu'on achète une paire de chaussettes
made in china qui est fabriqué pour 40
centimes et qui vous est vendu 12 euros
on se fait avoir
la sphère libyenne en parlions ouvert
pas dessus financement de campagne tout
se passe bien
je vous ai déjà dit que j'irai pour de
longues rangées pas fui le truc mais
j'avais des éléments du titre soucis
mais si j'avais des éléments et des
scoop je vous dirai quand voilà je n'ai
pas plus d'informations quant aux noms
peut-être même moins qu'en non ceux qui
nous écoutent donc je ne sais pas juger
préjugés par avance
assange
snedden oui
non pas un peu ou pas nous le pays des
droits de l'homme oui main sur le coeur
on la démocratie pour les villes et les
faibles et pauvres un tout un ton c'est
quoi c'est le droit d'asile est tracée
dans les tailles c'est quoi ces c'est de
l'impuissance essais on est on est
devenue un pays de moyenne impuissance
on n'est pas capable de dire bon et la
france ici
snowdon a montré que les états unis se
gaver sur les data des français sur leur
enseigner le renseignement économique
sur les boîtes françaises
s'étaient open bar open bar pour qu'on
lui donne pas l'asile pourquoi on est
obligé d'avoir la russie qui accorde
l'asile à snow deux ça fait partie des
parce qu'on n'est pas capable d'assurer
sa sécurité en france c'est parce qu'on
n'a pas de couilles avec les états unis
c'est parce qu'on avait pas d'
embrouille c'est par là on est sous le
robinet de leur enseignement s'est pas
relâchée par lâcheté ou par lâcheté moi
j'avais fait partie de ceux qui avaient
signé à l'époque où j'étais
parlementaire l'idée qu'il fallait
accueillir edouard snowdon enfin on a on
a accueilli on a accueilli l'ayatollah
khomeini
en france donc on est happé publie la
légion a qui doutent l'a déjà en
catimini la cl égyptien oui à 6,6 au
président s'il passe il enfin bon peu
importe mais je veux dire
oui je pense qu'on sait la lâcheté et la
lâcheté châtillon les pressions du
gouvernement américain c'est de la
lâcheté ou notre élite
française est infiltré par l'idéologie
américaine ou devenue dépendante
ou réseau américain je pense plutôt la
troisième solution
que je pense qu'une forme de dépendance
je pense que dans les grands jeux des
échanges de diplomatique c'est je te
donne ça tu me donnes ça ne me touche
pas là dessus je ne touche pas là dessus
la diplomatie a toujours été un grand
jeu 2-2 voulu
peut dire ça comme ça toujours été un
grand jeu des changes de bons mauvais
procédés ensemble et qu'effectivement
et bien sûr cette affaire c'est tombé
sur sur des deals qui se sont fait sur
le dos des droits de l'homme et que les
droits de l'homme ont bon dos dans un
certain nombre de cas voilà c'est là à
cesser leur aile politique c'est le
réalisme de ce qui se passe alors après
si on élargit le focus et qu'on regarde
globalement on reste quand même un pays
d'accueil des droits de l'homme est
porteur de ça mais sur quelques affaires
douloureuses on n'a pas été à la hauteur
où on est on est pas un pays parfait
message à son jeu qui en tout
l'angleterre où il n'y a pas de
chauffage où il se fait fouiller au
corps
il soit donc c'est de la torture ça non
c'est ce qu'on peut qualifier ça de 2
c'est une forme de torture oui
volontaire ou involontaire de la part de
ceux qui l'accueillent mais c'est une
forme de torture ont eu sur moi mais il
ya hélas on vous parlait de ceux qui
sont médiatiques qui sont médiatisés
dont on parle beaucoup mais il ya aussi
tellement en dehors des mailles du filet
il y en a aussi tellement dont on parle
jamais croupissent ont été victimes des
systèmes qui ont été victimes deux pas
de chance comme dirait l'autre ou coup
été victime de coups ils sont tombées en
dehors des systèmes qu'il faut c'est
bien de focaliser sur ce qu'ils sont
très médiatique faut pas oublier que
les démocraties ne sont loin d'être des
systèmes parfait
question internet salon va verser
ensemble le fait que sa gestion d'une
commune fut épinglé par la cour des
comptes aurait-il un commentaire nous
faire vu comme la cour des comptes
vérifie la gestion de toutes les
communes j'ai eu plusieurs rapports de
la chambre régionale des comptes ça n'a
jamais débouché sur aucune mise en cause
d'aucune sorte judiciaire après yeux des
critiques sur des choses qu'on peut
améliorer on peut toujours s'améliorer
et toute gestion qu'elles soient
individuelles privées d'entreprises aux
peut toujours s'améliorer donc jeu on
peut dire épinglée par la chambre
régionale des comptes j'aurais été
épinglés si j'avais connu des
illégalités ce qui n'a jamais été le cas
n'ai jamais été mises en examen je n'ai
jamais été
sur ces sujets là donc voilà j'assume
les erreurs qu'ont pu être fait quand on
gère une commune et des difficultés oui
ça peut arriver et là la chambre
régionale des comptes est là pour nous
aider à corriger les erreurs donc c'est
plutôt ça une dernière question que
pense-t-il de la vente d'armes par la
france aux saoudiens alors la vente
d'armes ça va des canons caesar au
laboratoire p4 est ce que est ce que les
saoudiens ce pays où on tronçonne les
journalistes dans les ambassades
il faut l'avoir à côté nous faut
continuer de leur parler faut continuer
à en parler quand même en on va être sûr
on va être sur le ski vous appelez grand
jeu de faux qc ca de 2 de la diplomatie
mais ont dit qu'ils ne recevraient
voilà moi je pense que la diplomatie
mondiale le grand équilibre nécessite de
parler à beaucoup de pays
orly paris il ya parlé parlé il ya ceux
qui se voient sur le devant de la scène
et ce qui peut faire avancer des vraies
causes parc de sceaux il ya les
pressions qui peuvent être faites
j'avoue que c'est des secteurs que je
connais assez mal celui de la diplomatie
jamais été diplomate de deux mondes mom
et de mon état et que j'ai un peu de mal
à juger c'est bien c'est mal il faut
celui-là enfin moi je suis toujours très
gêné par les jugements abrupts à
l'emporte-pièce sur tout ce talent porte
ou de 6 et un journaliste on en pense
qu'on en pense il a été terminée et il
ya courbit dans un pays à combien
d'autres qui ont été qu'on n'a pas vue
dont on n'a jamais parlé oui dans des
pays de sa veut dire qu'il faut si on ne
parle à aucun pays où les journalistes
sont malmenés ça va limiter les
relations diplomatiques est ce que les
diplomates dont je ne suis pas vous
l'avez compris mais vous je me faisais
d'avocat du diable j'ai bien compris
mais les diplomates vous dirai aussi que
si on parle pas on fait pas avancer les
causes et qu'on a fait libérer des gens
qu'on grâce un certain nombre de choses
on pourrait vous parler de la libye
parler des infirmières bulgares d'un
certain nombre de sujets ou où les
droits de l'homme ont pour le coup
progressé parce que dalle mate ou de la
femme de sarkozy là non je parle des
infirmières bulgares williams bulgare
n'y a pas eu d'histoire avec la fin de
sarkozy je parle des infirmières
bulgares qui ont été
libérés grâce à l'intervention de la
france sur ce sujet on pourrait parler
d'ingrid betancourt et d'un certain
nombre d'autres sujets où la diplomatie
a permis des succès elle est pas belle
est loin d'être parfaite moi je suis je
suis gêné par donner des jugements du
type qui sait tout et qui veut tout
juger sur des sujets où je suis pas
forcément un grand spécialiste moi je te
le dire
est ce cas où le cannabis en france est
ce que est ce qu'on peut faire du
cannabis médine france oui j'espère que
sur ce qui va arriver sur le cbd sur le
le l'aspect à la fois médicale et
bien-être de quelque chose de réguler on
aura des filières médine france oui
parce que ce serait le paradoxe que on
ouvre un peu les portes de cette
consommation et que les quelques
dizaines de milliards ou voire centaines
de milliards de ce marché on se fasse
importer des produits qui viennent
d'ailleurs de chez nous donc j'espère
que il y aura des filières nationales
tout ça dans nos rangs dans un débat
clair démocratique régulé où on confond
pas le bien-être est la drogue et on a
un aspect qui est un aspect santé qui
est à prendre en compte aussi oui ça
bouge ça bouge beaucoup c'est en train
d'évoluer sur sur ce sujet mais pour le
coup il faut y accrocher une filière
industrielle économique
agricole française oui bien sûr les
meilleurs comme d'habitude je sais pas
si on sera les meilleurs enthousiaste et
où vous avez plutôt windows ou linux
je suis plutôt windows vous êtes plutôt
windows
la marque de vos chaussettes mes
chaussettes elles viennent d'une
entreprise qui
je les achète à la boutique de
l'assemblée nationale qui est ouverte à
tous deux membres et elles viennent
d'une entreprise qui est à montceau les
mines comment combien je les achète
autour de 20 euros
c'est de la bonne came oui oui elles
tiennent bien le choc quoi réellement
très haut donc j'aime les chaussettes
qui manteau je peux pas vous les montrer
c'est des pinces
[Rires]
parce que vous avez déjà fumé un joint
non je n'ai jamais fumé ni à joigny une
cigarette jamais fumé de cigarette dans
ma vie c'est un cigare oui
j'ai dû fumer dix à douze cigare dans ma
vie j'ai bien à quel prix la
libéralisation des infirmières à quel
prix la libération d un chargeur sais
pas
mais c'est tout le débat vous faites
rien pour libérer des gens vous dites
c'est un scandale vous les aidez pas et
vous mettez un prix pour libérer vous
dites c'est un scandale vous avez payé
trop cher comme quoi ça ne va jamais
quoi c'est compliqué à un référendum
d'initiative populaire ou initiatives
civiques je suis très partisan et je
trouve que on la crée et met la barre
est beaucoup trop haute sur ce sujet et
que nos amis suisses qu'on évoquait tout
à l'heure ont une pratique de la
démocratie référendaire qui est
intéressante
vous dernière le franc cfa c'est midi en
france
ces deux français y fassent est une
c'est une s'éteint
une monnaie déclinante
comme la france ne
sait pas s'il faut le regretter s'il
faut voilà
ccc le franc cfa est issu du nippo d'une
époque post coloniale qui est en train
de s'achever je pense qu'il faut rester
très proche moi je j'ai été vice
président de la fondation borloo pour
l'énergie en afrique je pense que le
dialogue entre l'europe et l'afrique et
à dialogue indispensable que si on
additionne l'europe et l'afrique ont le
centre du monde et là autour de nous et
qu'additionner l'europe l'afrique c'est
pas si compliqué c'est m 27 26 chefs
d'état d'un côté 54 de l'autre ensemble
et leur dire voilà on va faire des
choses ensemble on va doubler nos
universités on va jumelées nos
entreprises on va travailler ensemble on
va pas faire on va pas faire de l'aide
au développement
on va faire du co développement on va
faire de la coke croissance on va
grossir ensemble on va on va s'entendre
et on va travailler ensemble ce serait
absolument formidable et je trouvais
qu'ils peuvent être réticents après la
françafrique oui je comprends bien sûr
qu'il puisse être été 100 mais je
comprends aussi que la jeunesse
d'afrique elle a les yeux rivés sur
l'europe
notamment à travers les smartphones à
travers cette vitrine en direct sur
l'europe échos font travailler ensemble
ccc serait une intelligence collective
et je pense que si le repas doit
renaître de ses cendres institutionnel
c'est sans doute sur des souverainetés
mais c'est aussi sur la main tendue à
l'afrique europe + afrique c'est
l'équation du 21e siècle et si on arrive
à faire ça on aura sauvé peut-être même
le monde je parle avec beaucoup
d'emphase mon aura sauvé le monde et
qu'on a tous ils ont on a les
consommateurs on allait savoir faire on
allait marcher on a les hommes on à la
terre on à l'agriculture on a on à
l'énergie avec le soleil et avec notre
capacité on a tous voila est-ce que pour
revenir à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
sur les parlementaires est ce que 54
chefs d'état africains et 26 chefs
d'état européens c'est à dire 80
personnes on peut pas les enfermer muret
les portes du château de versailles
alors dire mettez vous d'accord sur un
projet ambitieux à 20 ans un peu
saoudiennes ont un peu à la vatican
saoudienne n'est plus de résultats pas
sûr est-ce que vous avez un ami
imaginaire
un ami imaginaire non vous croyez en
dieu oui vous avez un imaginez alors
c'est pas un ami tu es une force
une force imaginaire c'est une force
intérieure
de la messe non
on peut croire en dieu sans avoir sa
propre pratique
est ce que vous pouvez conseillez trois
livres à notre communauté oui je peux
conseiller le prince des marées qui pour
moi est un des plus beaux livres que
j'ai lus de pat conroy d'un livre un
énorme bouquin mais qui est un livre
absolument
formidable
je peux
conseiller alors après c'est plus d'un
livre mais c'est toute la série des
rougon-macquart est d aulas a bercé ma
jeunesse et mon enfant mais c'est des
classiques qui sont absolument
formidable qui est à la fois une plongée
dans l'histoire dans l'histoire sociale
dans les personnages dans les
personnalités
bon ça fait plus de trois l'impasse que
si on prend tous les rayons macquart
c'est une sacrée série et puis qu'est-ce
que je peux conseiller d'autres
comme bouquin
non voilà je sais bien ça fait plus de
trois et que vous avez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
fouet parce que j'ai des fils
cetc
réfléchissez à ce que sont vos gros
caillou
connaissez l'histoire c'est ce
professeur américain qui explique à ses
élèves pour son dernier cours et qui
leur demandent si le saut est plein sera
so de de sousse sa table il il remplit
gros cailloux et il dit est ce que le
saut est plein les élèves du 10 où il
est plein il sort un seau de sable
univers sable et le sable rempli les ce
que maintenant c'est plein désert oui
maintenant c'est plat il sort un seau
d'eau ayant rempli d'eau et le soc
rempli et il leur explique que la
philosophie de cette démonstration c'est
que s'il avait mis d'abord l'eau eh ben
ils pouvaient plus mettre le reste s'il
avait mis d'abord le sable ils pouvaient
plus y mettre le reste est que dans la
vie il faut d'abord choisir ses gros
caillou qu'est ce qui est important pour
vous et puis après ce qui est moins
important est ce que encore moins
important une très belle philosophie de
vie bien je dirais à la jeunesse
choisissez vos gros caillou qu'est ce
qui est important pour vous voilà moi je
sais ce qui est important pour moi ce
qui est important pour moi c'est ma
liberté et et je vais avoir 60 ans dans
quelques jours j'aspire à être le plus
libre possible avec les contraintes de
la vie c'est ma famille les miens et
puis c'est la rencontre avec les autres
mais je pense que l'exercice qu'on peut
demander à la jeunesse c'est de choisir
ses gros cailloux et puis après de
mettre les plus petits cailloux et les
choses plus plus difficile et ça peut
vous porter toute une vie yves jégo
merci
[Musique]